alors lumière machin on bouge plus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin que vous bon je vous faire une
nouvelle interview pour vous spécial
pour vous celle là c'est l'interview
petit fils à faire à pied à vélo ou bien
alors c'est très simple je vais vous
citer tout un tas de maladies
pathologique psychologique et les deux
perversion et vous avez bien si vous
êtes comme ça exhibitionniste de moins
en moins ah bon ouais ouais vous fermez
fermez les volets non je crois que c'est
le fait de faire de la scène me permet
d'accepter de l'être moins d'être plus
pudiques maintenant c'est comme moi les
gens viennent finalement je vais des
gens tellement bien dans les missions
que j'ai pas besoin d'en faire
norris embête pas michel n'ont jamais
fait une sortie attendue serait dont moi
ça fait cinq mois et demi je suis pas
sorti et chandon terminer un roman
voilà là il a un peu mal à briser
complètement mais moiselle michel et
rigorisme ce soir auprès de répondre à
pierre s'ils voulaient alors masochiste
vous savez quand vous fasse mal
j'ai des mauvaises habitudes à ce niveau
là encore c'est à dire que mais c'est la
dernière fois
c'est à dire que je crois vraiment que
dans le le sadisme ou masochisme il ya
beaucoup qui nous vient faire comme tout
d'ailleurs qui nous vient des schémas
qu'on a appris et que si on a vu des
gens d'autres familles qui sont
malheureux on a tendance à se dire ah
bah ouais c'est vachement bien être
malheureux et la tendance à l'être voilà
donc je me soigne alors est ce que vous
êtes schizophrène dédoublement de
personnalité
non non non aucune d'asie oui je crois
où il parle il a un petit peu oui
parfois oui pierre veut pas parler ce
matin au caire
oui on est un peu parano c'est normal
comment on explosé avant et forcément
c'est vrai ce qu il lui résiste devenu
résident
c'est quoi ça c'est à lombard dont jaar
et ird et a demandé à des âges non
hystérique vous êtes heu pardon michel
tout le monde à 12 ans est-ce que vous
avez de la narcolepsie
c'est quoi ça c'est quand on s'endort
n'importe quoi n'importe comment comme
raymond barre
j'arrive à m'endormir amende or mais
j'arrive à m'en dormait nous attend mais
mais c'est pas le contraindre à la
pathologie c'est mériterait bien dans
notre métier de pouvoir dormir un quart
d'heure et la narcolepsie c'est quand on
sait pas quand on va s'endormir
oui c'est vu des chiens comme ça c'est
génial centre a trait aux blessés ils
sont très contents et ils voient leur
plein arriver bon ben c'est ça qu'il
allait mais sérieusement vous savez la
bombarde ses skis la narcolepsie
écoutez je m'endors à toutes les
conférences ont compris parfois aux
miennes l'apéro c'est toi c'est existe
peur d'eux des films pornos non c'est
bien il n'aime pas du tout les cas de
cette bande est ce que la porno phobie
c'est quand on a peur de l'acte sexuel
c'est marrant ce cas voilà ça vous
chante et ça a l'air de bus ont cessé il
ya un truc terrible j'avais trouvé mais
c'est la pente aux phobies phobie de la
déconnade nord c'est au tour de taille
et à sa vie c'était pas bête cela
c'était pas mal mais c'est rare alors
maintenant hop le port des pantalons
non
ça vienne forte hausse c'est avant tout
ce qui veut dire tout est bien la honte
aux phobies c'est d'avoir peur de tout
il ya des gens comme ça moi on verdict
vous n'êtes pas si folle que ça je m'en
merci bonsoir allumer la lumière
voilà je fais un voeu fait une petite
interview comme vous étiez un petit peu
caractériel j'étais à ta loopsi alors
attention là parce que pendant jingle
vous avez l'habitude des garçons bouge
pas il faut pas bouger
oui
tu as un peu bougé j'ai regardé rouge
caméra il fallait retenir son souffle
tout tout tout tout ça mais non c'est
dur c'est cette émission est un peu dure
tout l'été 2008 à la respiration des
invités me le dit souvent il était
richard non m'avait dit que dans cet
hymne genre de blague
non666 revenue comme le père à l'an 2000
sera paix ou ne sera pas bon alors
richard bohringer vous êtes prêts oui
alors interview psy donc un est-ce que
vous avez des toc c'est à dire des tous
des troubles obsessionnels compulsifs
tir gens vous remontez fermer le gaz de
l'eure voulais faire mais oui oui oui
attention parce qu'on a tout fait à la
fin pour y siéger il déclaré fu peas et
oui ça sera plus la baisse de 26 ce sera
une mise au vert
[Applaudissements]
parano oui est ce que vous êtes schizo
oui est ce que vous êtes salle d'eau non
attendez on n'avait pas ça ne vous aimez
pas faire mal n'ont même pas pensé le
bout des seins n'ont même pas passé je
n'ai pas moi je suis là aussi pour faire
plaisir
oui attendez si ça fait plaisir passer
de vous dire si ça fait plaisir je
devais tout mais je suis passé à
dommages aux il ya des filles qui ça
fait plaisir c'est rigolo
alors est ce que vous êtes exhibe au nom
bien vous vous baladez pas à poil devant
la flamme voisine qui n'ont non ya pas
deux voisines scato ah non alors jusqu'à
thonon travelo non tu dis rien plus tard
c'est la roue non je ne suis pas bon est
ce que vous êtes
hypo est-ce que tu as une fois go ça
pouvait faire partie du cast vous êtes
fous rires est-ce que vous êtes
hydrophobe je ne sais pas ce que ça veut
dire
or denis drôle au globe j'aime pas
j'aime pas l'eau hm là aussi ça vous
aimez le maillot orange et bleu n'ont
même pas vous être nikto fob je me
rassure tout de suite ça linda b ne
cherchez pas un truc ça veut dire quoi
votre avenir
la foi biblique non non ça c'est porno
fob adjet porno fob non ouais donc nikto
femmes non c'est des gens qui ont peur
de la nuit tout simplement dans cette
panique le fleuve
non non non est ce que vous êtes bléneau
non baîllonné fob oui alors c'est la
peur de bruno bellone je suis quelqu'un
de la biture ah non non pas du tout pas
du tout et pour terminer à ce que vous
êtes à nemo fob c'est pas le mec aime
pas anémone animaux fox c'est le mec
aime pas levant ah non moi j'aime
j'adore le vent alors ce moment vous
avez été servis
la pente au flop aussi que j'avais
appris avec van tho fausses et celui qui
aime les pantoufles
voilà c'est lui qui a peur de tout voilà
[Musique]
bien la forme elle progresse il vient
d'ailleurs on valoir sylvain hardy a
progressé vacances en thaïlande
d'après ce talent et massage thaï non
j'ai pas pris mais vous me marierai
jamais j'ai des copains qui ont essayé
ils n'ont pas voulu me raconter bons
amis sont allés faire des cobayes je
mettais en thaïlande dont jacques
bompard a été avant d'être avec elle
cette façon bon je vous laisse dans les
mains de linda bon alors là attention
donc c'est l'interview jeu drôle à
l'état c'est la seule que j'ai trop
attention attention
[Musique]
richard si vous étiez une femme à qui
marc yevou ressembler à ma femme
et le cantal et qu'elle fantasme
quelles seraient vos fantasmes rage
écoutez quitte à vous décevoir ses
basiques moi ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que choses toutes simples mais je
fais les oui je fais ce qu'il fait
plaisir et donc si vous étiez cette
femme là vote quelle serait sa serait
pas votre pire cauchemar
si vous deviez vivre avec richard
bohringer ben c'est de vivre règle est
vrai que là en l'occurrence
clp partir tous les deux sur une île
déserte
quel sera le programme a le programme il
soit une île déserte vraiment déserte
ouais oui ça veut dire personne d'autre
non ça veut dire faire ça vraiment on
n'y va pas non non ils apprennent cio
peut être tous les deux au milieu des
autres mondes
vous avez dit un jour la générosité des
hommes s'arrête là où commence celle des
femmes fois nous expliquer parce que
j'ai trouvé plus généreuse que nous
aimons tous les gonzesses dans la poche
sont deux soeurs
parce qu'après il ya d'autres trucs
moins plaisant vainqueur n'a pas de
poste dans son truc bien georges
wolinski heures a dit un jour ça c'est
pour notre dernière question les hommes
adorent l'école c'est pour ça qu'ils ont
tout fait pendant des siècles pour
qu'elle le reste
c'est très joli mais c'est un mot c'est
un mou très spirituelle mais non sur le
fond on peut pas village de l'expliquer
merci linda je crois que vous l'avez
l'idée c'était de le déstabiliser en
déstabilisant car et bien finie vous
avez phénoménal vous fait quoi là je
vais faire je vous tester à balard
allez-y c'est quoi le test c'est
l'interview psy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
minable c'est dire hier bissau est
capable d'expliquer on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle michel non c'est guy
bedos
bon alors allons-y c'est tout simplement
c'est une interview psy c'est pour
savoir quel est votre état psychique
après une seule jambe et seniors se sent
un peu plus intimes comme ça pour savoir
quel est votre état psychique après une
semaine de promotion sur la plage
est ce que vous êtes dépressives ou je
vous êtes névrosé non plus c'est zéro
défaut jeudi elle s'est érodée en inédit
parano ça m'arrive un oui dans quelles
circonstances
puis quand votre jules tourner avec
leonardo dicaprio doute un peu mais je
le vis très mal je vous êtes schizo non
quand même est-ce que vous êtes exhibo
ah non ça se dit ça avec vous
nadja check in on est un peu exhib ou
retourner avec russes en même temps ça
fait cher exhibo mais je pense pas que
ça se dit quand même se dit que ce genre
de deal exhibitionniste zibouh
franchement exhibo en existe et que j'ai
dit exit vie c'est quand on était gosses
est ce que vous êtes
alors ça c'est très drôle est ce que
vous êtes porno fob sais ce que c'est
par nos frais
j'imagine je ne suis pas ne pas
supporter le porno c'est la première que
je vois qu'ils connaissent a dit non car
tu déconnes ou quoi
tout trouvé là parce que c'est du grec
ancien vous allez voir c'est du grec
ancien de les voir je vous êtes stade au
château m'arrivait un des fosses une
petite perversion est ce que vous êtes
sac à dos 1er mars que tout autant que
vous êtes en virginie ledoyen aussi la
paire généralement quand c'est minimum
hystéro nous agirons tôt à un peu quand
même dit la vérité là j'ai la réponse
toute façon un peu peut-être ne pouvais
pas me mentir c'est quoi jérôme giron
tôt les personnes âgées
voilà elle aime les gens un peu plus âgé
qu'elle et virginie est encadrée elle
aime bien avoir des gens elle a bien
être avec des hommes un peu plus et
sexuelle géronto ça dénature
gérontophilie c'est la france qu'on a
pour des gens un peu plus d'une jeune
qui va là dessus et ridiculise chérif
c'est la foi qui nous inviterons à dîner
les additions son élan titulaire 10 ans
en gentil fétichiste non voyeuriste un
peu quand même
des fois je me disais qu'est ce que
permet à ce palais des foires cette
perversion mais j'en ai plein mais
heureusement les actrices on est chez
nous
agora fin mais pas bien qu'aucun les
agoraphobes elle n'aime pas la foule
ah je croyais elle avait peur des
araignées ce morceau
alors que vous pouvez trouver ça est ce
que vous êtes canaux fob je sais moi ça
en plus elle une faute du jcc quoique
nous face à la peur du mari de barbie
ouais
gp du greco circle of ob 11 ans et
l'autre comme c'est celle qui a peur de
l'obscurité
après sa nuit fob justement est-ce que
vous êtes nikto fob non je sers nous ces
masques on croit au sérieux sérieux nick
touristes à la nuit j'ai la vie on dit
voilà ces gens quand la nuit est ce que
vous êtes et lourau fob si tu sais pas
par contre ça c'est la honte c'est
d'être pas elle nous rend malheureux
c'est ce que ces maximes et l'europhobe
c'est vrai qu'en ces gens qui ont peur
des chats en a la preuve est ce que vous
êtes sinophobe ça c'est pour maxime sa
maxime n'est pas sinophobe dans la baie
de somme ils sont pas si nos familles
cynophiles ils sont cynophiles on s'est
compris le complicité entre bien
d'autres jeux que tu crois
attends rassoit le crâne quand même
riche cbc le plus dur est ce que vous
êtes aérodrome octobre trois là bas tout
le monde quoi que c'est la peur des
aérodromes
non non c'est la paire les aéroports
c'est la peur des avions dont elle avait
dit sophie sophie attend pas faire ça
quand on veut faire
est ce que vous êtes sidero de romo fob
jeu c'est au nom la foire était ce jeu
par contre 1 027 jean sans peur du train
d'assécher qu à ce jour c'est la soupe
c'est pourquoi est-ce que vous êtes coco
fob mais on adore la noix de coco
non pas du tout non tu possèdes coco ça
se termine bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est formidable c'est derrière sow et
caf a expliqué on ne bouge pas pendant
le jingle ça c'est formidable c'est
énorme
dites-moi interview si donc on va faire
un petit tour de votre psychisme
d'accord est ce que vous êtes parano ça
m'arrive donc l occasion mais j'ai droit
à des jockeys ou pas attendez si vous
avez vous prenez des jokers c'est encore
nina et géra qui répondent à votre place
non non je suis parano quand je suis pas
très bien dans ma peau et quand
préféré répondre vous finalement m vous
fumez trop de cigarettes
c'est dégueulasse il s'est arrêté vous
avez arrêté à moitié un motif est
adorable
est ce que vous êtes schizo pas du tout
enfin ça peut non non ça va de ce côté
là ça va est ce que vous êtes maso non
enfin envers moi même ça peut m'arriver
aussi vous fait du mal je vais pas me
faire du mal à moi même way est ce que
vous aimez quand vous fasse du mal non
ça vous plaît pas ça est ce que vous
êtes sa dos à dos vous aimez faire mal
non ce n'est pas demain non ça me plait
pas bien mais jusque là ça va
est ce que vous êtes sado maso ça rend
la prod ou ce c'est bien connu
non moi je préfère qu'elles soient
douces en douceur donc je suis pas du
tout pour la violence est ce que vous
êtes gérant tôt je sais pas ce que c'est
geron tous et des filles qui aiment bien
les vieux vieux me doutais bien vieux je
sais pas ce que c'est exactement vieux
non plus vieux comme moi quoi mais moi
je ne trouve pas vieux par exercer non
mes vieux genre vieux à partir de 60 70
non je suis pas gironde toile alors
d'accord mais jusqu'à quel âge vous êtes
jusqu'à quel âge irons tous à partir de
quel âge 50 ça va encore est ce que vous
êtes porno je peux vous aimez regarder
des cassettes des machines dans ce sens
là pas du tout pas du tout non je suis
pas du tout bord noir j'aime pas ça
pousse ça pousse alors je peux être
porno mais pas à pas vous regardez
jamais de films pornos par exemple
jamais non franchement ça me vous
ferriez retrouve pas taper dans le tas
c'est normal comme puis y'a assez
vous ne regardez jamais non plus
bouricha moi je regarde pas parce que le
cas je m'en sert presque jamais il faut
attendre un quart d'heure se ressentir
pendant huit jours c'est vrai faut
tisser un quart d'heure
non j'ai pas mal
et vous jamais pas faire participer moi
à oui je vais le voir à la télé tu
comptes c'est marrant mais moi je
préfère participer
ouais vas faire rétracte est ce que vous
êtes vdo celle inverse de géronto je dis
ça pour nos amis téléspectateurs qui
n'ont pas l'habitude de tous ces maux
pédo hannon paix de non plus vous êtes
au jeu vous êtes travelo vous a déjà
tenté la disons vous est vachement
sérieuses comme fille à bas ces trucs
normaux et que j'utilise la journée
c'est les déviations les plus communes
dépenser c'est vrai c'est le top 15 des
déviations des français ça là je préfère
normal que sérieuse bon je faisais de
disco pour que nos amis téléspectateurs
puissent se faire une idée très précise
sur le mental le psychisme des mathieu
bayle
on va faire une petite interview psy et
on ne bouge pas dans la jungle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voulez vous relaxer un petit peu avant
de commencer
[Musique]
c'est tout bon dario n'oublie pas ton
petit chapeau non tirs des bonbons c'est
vrai que moi
[Applaudissements]
c'est un chant traditionnel tibétain
j'ai vu gong li la télévision cette
semaine dire que le tibet est une
province de la chine durant les jo
league anglais alors est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas un an
non pas vraiment est ce que vous êtes
schizo temps en temps avec mon travail
avec votre travail vous êtes maso tant
de temps à jouer des mecs qui est ce que
vous êtes sadou est patron non je vous
êtes sado-maso bon patronat géronto
géronto c'est quand on aime les
personnes plus âgées
le personnage vraiment mais c'est pas
vraiment bref c'est pas votre truc non
est ce que vous êtes porno ça veut dire
qu'on regarde et que cette temps ce
temps je crois les pour nous c'est bien
[Rires]
je vois ma fille je vois la divine dans
le fond là bas qui se dit mais qu'est ce
que je fous là camarades bien est-ce que
vous êtes fétiche au nom exhibo oui à
adam aux normes et mon travail c'est
vraiment sexy
est ce que vous êtes pitot non bien sûr
non une fille les deux ans plus jeune
maman c'est un peu ce que vous êtes aux
ânes on n'en passe pas exactement j'ai
bien non merci beaucoup et marne
aubel sa lumière ne bouge pas par le
jingle bells est bon
alors je vous faire virginie et chorales
et une petite interview psy c'est tombé
sur vous voulez pas répondre comme avis
on va voir façon virginie peu sinon pas
comme avec edouard baer c'est brialy qui
avait pour moi non abbassi 6,6 alors est
ce qu est ce que vous êtes parano les
filles moi un peu ouais enfin bon il
faut qu'il faut voir si vous êtes schizo
way totalement non bah non apparemment
non puisque il n'y a pas de différence
entre votre vie professionnelle et votre
vie privée vous dites que ça fait partie
de moi j'ai beaucoup de facettes
différentes mais sa passe est sans aucun
problème très bien qu'aurel est ce que
vous êtes sado vaguement quand même vous
aimez bien faire mal ouais j'aime bien
des mazots sont pas trop mais par contre
ça dauger pratiqué pendant que je vais
beaucoup plus jeune vous avez fait la
dominatrice
oui et alors alors c'était rigolo mais
on s'en lasse ah oui on sent là le signe
alors vous êtes exhibo oui vous coralie
on le sait vous l'avez dit relais votre
époque gothique en vous et l'amant sur
la scène de la loco virginie est ce que
vous êtes exhibo non non
souviendra peut-être s'ébattent géronto
pourquoi pas j'ai honte aux noirs et
gérant taux est ce que le noir est
gérante au voilà est-ce que vous êtes
pédo jamais plus j'aime plus les garçons
que les hommes en fait voilà donc c'est
un peu pédo je reconnais cipres excuse
est zoo voilà non non jamais jamais
essayé des bois est ce que vous êtes
ayrault c'est quoi ouais pourquoi pas
ouais je vous ai de coco arrive
moi j'ai tout essayé sauf l'hérault en
fait vous êtes coco 12 états d'âme au
nom de l'amour c'est l'amour
la version c'est la pire de toutes ses
habits de l'an dernier vous n'êtes pas
d'amour
c'est vrai m tombe la neige danone est
ce que vous êtes disco
non pas spécifiquement si j'ai beaucoup
bu pourquoi pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà on va commencer avec vous michel
est ce que vous êtes accro à l'alcool
non non à la cigarette non vous n'êtes
pas accro à la cigarette au cigare au
cigare alors en parlant de cigarettes je
voudrais répondre à un email de garçon
qui s'appelle libéral un mec qui
s'appelle libéral pas très libéral ils
me reprochent
en dix ans on fume sur votre plateau bah
oui moi les gens font ce qu'ils veulent
c'est vrai puisque quand darmon fume si
je m'engueule c'est pas parce qu'il fume
c'est parce qu'il écoute pas guy forget
voilà est ce que vous êtes
mythos comme tous les paranos vous êtes
mytho mythomane
peut-être peut-être un peu vous je
déteste
vous détestez les mythomanes parano est
parano comme tous les skyzos way est ce
que vous êtes canaux audio et argentan
et de temps en temps vous avez peur vous
sentez que le monde entier contre vous
ça vous arrive le matin la guerre ce qui
est des provinces et comme atik sécurité
qu'elles aient les gens n'étaient pas là
michael et vous vous êtes par abandon
mais ça m'est arrivé mais quelques
petites fois ses films l'étranger pour
la whey pas autant d alors
mareva est ce que vous êtes maso ou est
ce que vous aimez quand on vous fait mal
ça dépend où
à sa défense il encourt et comment ça
dépend où et comment mais vous n'êtes
pas content le principe je les adore
cette marque
est ce que vous vous êtes masoe mais
quand vous fasse mal un peu en aveux et
sky sports vous mort quand on foule mort
c'est maintenant la non mais j'aime bien
les mauvaises critiques que j'adore oui
mes rivaux d'accord il est maso s'adosse
attaché maso comme tous les ados alors
vous tient les histoires de l'histoire
du mazeau guy dos à dos fais moi mal
social aux usines aux lots dieu merci
génial c'est très bonne histoire geste
est ce que vous êtes exhibo c'est-à-dire
exhibitionniste escales miami par
exemple chez vous promener à poil avec
juste un tee shirt
même si des voisins regardent ça vous
aimez vous montrer un peu tout non non
non je voudrais c'est fini mamie sexo
série finit là non mais non non non je
me permets de démissionner dans la
maison nous met dans la maison a besoin
oui tu as raison c'est tout voilà les
ardennes ouais vous êtes tout nu chez
vous moi ça s'appelle pas de
l'exhibitionnisme c'est que j'ai grandi
tout nus et en maillot de bain non mais
parce qu'à tahiti
quand on est enfant ben on est tout le
temps à la plage oui vous êtes encore
une enfant exactement bon est ce que
vous êtes porno comme tous les barjots
comme tous les barjots très bien vous
n'êtes pas en osier vous aimez les
cassettes pornos vous regardez des films
[Applaudissements]
ouais
et vous savez chacun peut dernière
question est ce que vous êtes julio ma
maman est très hermès jaser âmes à celle
qui varie pas du jardin taman parce que
j'étais obligé d'être avec ma maman donc
du coup on devient julio exactement mais
maintenant que tu me connais tu y vas
donner de plus en plus elle est très
drôle you merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
didier
[Musique]
[__] ma fille tu fais chier tabosa je
suis allé deux là impeccable mais qu'est
ce que c'est laurent dix ans je suis le
chef de file des gens qui ne comprennent
pas cette des chevilles et je suis
rentré je vais suivre l'avis même
prendre le maquis ce soir tu verras la
france gronde
tu ne t'en rends pas compte tirer jeunes
enfants enchaîne bien aurélie dupont est
ce que vous êtes mito non est ce que
vous êtes schizo non c'est bien
est ce que vous êtes parano c'est pour
moi un petit peu à l'opéra c'est
tellement ça va mieux un petit peu
parade bien vous êtes maso forcément un
peu pour faire ce boulot là il fait de
la trentaine bah oui les taux
resteraient toi devant une barre pendant
des hommes les chaussures enfin vous
vous êtes ado
pas encore pas encore ce qui veut dire
tout peut arriver en même temps techcite
quoi faire si vous êtes exhibo vous
aimez bien me promener tout nu devant la
fenêtre je veux pas forcément ça met un
peu exhib oui forcément de danse et 1 5
million d'êtres de se dévoiler un peu en
scène c'est un peu exhib est ce que vous
êtes jérôme taux par rapport à 90 par
rapport à tout le monde comme on voudra
voir moi aussi c'est quand on aime les
gens plus âgés visage et comme vous ça
dépend entre 50 ans de plus et des andes
plus d'un an de plus pourquoi pas vrai
dix ans de plus pourquoi pas vous avez
quel âge j'ai bientôt 28
ça fait trente huit combinés dans le
baba alors est ce que vous êtes
quand je dis porno séparé ce que vous
regardez cassettes pornos cette borne
vous regarder je veux pas de cassettes
ça m'est arrivé de zapper et de regarder
ça me fait beaucoup rire
en fait je sache les bars et des travail
j'ai regardé comme tout le monde quoi
qui n'a pas regardé un film tendu dans
un film porno ici commentaire ta femme
c'est à dire que yaya le scénario est
toujours le même alors ouais pas
tellement et quand on l'a vu on l'a tous
vu ces normes sont pas toujours le même
nombre
non c'est pas ça l'action est ce que
vous êtes disco
là
vous
[Musique]
là tu te bouges la non là je suis
d'accord c'est génial c'est ça qui
m'énerve je suis en train de chercher un
nom pour l'association
bah c'est un trek on les balance c'est à
dire que y'a un moment donné mais
balance hésite beaucoup et un moment
donné elles ont décidé
et alors là c'est plus ça s'est très
très mal à ma voiture et là aussi vous
cela je vous dise tellement changeant
j'en sais rien peut-être à mon avis
j'essaye tous les signes et beaucoup en
fonction de ce qui vient germi d'air
donc interview psy est ce que vous êtes
mito ses nerfs mythomane oui et en gère
la plupart un menu de pâques c'est pas
de la bonne graine non pas si vous êtes
mythos ans ce au sens courant de
l'acceptation du terme
non mais pas mytho - est-ce que vous
êtes schizo toujours au sens courant du
terme
bah oui non vous n'êtes pas me dire non
à chaque fois non plus non mais je vous
répond sincèrement qu'ils aient ou non
ya pas deux gérard miller nom lui est
parano pas du tout vous êtes maso non
mais pas qu'on fasse un peu mal non
d'abord essayé à non mais moi je fais
pas d'amour avec un nom assez seulement
dans l'amour qu'ont fait mal à bras
quand on est maso c'est dans l'amour que
ça non seulement n'ont pas seulement un
pas seulement est ce que vous êtes en
genre et pas où voter aussi massivement
jacques chirac
on va mettre 20 15 personnes qu'est-ce
que vous êtes sado pas du tout non plus
sérieusement sado-maso pas du tout
exhibo alors vraiment pour vous donner
un oui à mon jeu non mais attendez je
fais de la télévision non vous promener
à poil devant votre fenêtre on se change
votre voisine beauregard a donc là c'est
un sens plus exacte du terme
d'exhibitionnisme n'ont alors pas du
tout pas du tout non vous balader jamais
par exemple sur la plage avec un slip
moule ball
non est ce que vous êtes cassettes
pornos cassettes pornos non il y avait
un des deux termes où j'aurais pu
répondre oui mais cette forme est ce que
vous êtes gérant taux pas du tout ne
vais pas les vieilles pas au sens au
sens de l'amour au sens où son physique
oui j'aime bien les vieux oui plutôt et
pas ou c'est non seulement mon nom je
vous êtes plus d'entrées un peu de ton
sur ton quand on vieillit ça devient oui
c'est vrai voyez vue plutôt pédo alors
non plus parce que feydeau c'est en
dessous de la loi et de la tolérance
humaine
non non pas du tout mais je n'avais le
droit j'ai rajouté de la loi et de la
tolérance humaine non non non c'est
blake tolérance humaine c'est à dire que
je suis pour qu'à certains moments la
loi coïncide avec cette idée qu'on se
fait de l'humanité est ce que vous êtes
au fond rouge
ces lots c'est un plus trop tard vous
n'êtes pas doué pour que les gens
répondent oui 1
pourquoi moi parce que je réponde non il
y en a qui m'ont jamais personne n'a dit
oui là je vais vous dire franchement
êtes fétiche au nom fétiche au nom
travelo prêche non mais c'est amusant
c'est que finalement votre idée de
l'interview psy c'est un m l interview
qui se situe entièrement du côté de la
perversion bahraoui non c'est non aucun
point dans ce qu'il faut que vous
sachiez c'est que de tous les patients
que les psychanalystes voit ce ne voit
quasiment jamais c'est lé pervers à la
main un masochiste jamais un
exhibitionniste quasiment jamais devient
voir un psychanalyste pourquoi parce
qu'il sait parfaitement quel est son
objet de jouissance il n'a pas besoin de
s'allonger sur un divan pour savoir
parce qu'il a besoin ce dont il a besoin
je vous êtes disco disco
maintenant vous dire d'accord mais je
crois que les verts version
on va vous faire une petite interview
très sérieuse la route est longue
attention on ne bouge pas pendant le
dingle rouge
bush merde la révolution personne bouge
par le single se voulant oui gérer c'est
fou les sujets religieux de la même
couleur berling et dave
oui c'est vrai que c'est beau mais ça
change rien ne marche mieux que limoux
blaireau qu'au début est-ce que vous
n'êtes pas beaucoup dit ça avec gibeau
oui et djibo oui alors vous alors c'est
quelqu'un qui est exceptionnel c'est un
staff à oui oui comme tous les acteurs
le sens et on serait pas d'accord oui
mais moi je les enfants peuvent l'être
aussi des fois oui oui vous marcher nu
devant les fenêtres et cette audience
sera rien ça c'est pour faire plus de
trois ans que j'ai je marche nu devant
ma fenêtre il ya une espèce de rideau
rouge fermé tous les jours tous les
jours à longueur de journée et que de
temps en temps un quart d'heure par jour
leur aide souvent
j'aimerais enfin michel jammes habite en
face de chez vous vous sentez de te
parle un belge voit jean claude gayssot
quand j'ai vu que j'avais rassurez-vous
jean-claude monsieur le ministre vous
poser ce genre de questions bien alors
on continue est ce que vous êtes un faux
nom maso sauf quand je tape des hits de
l'été renom mais bon bien négocié un peu
maso ah ouais c'est bien on va la
refaire à tous les deux la papeterie
[__] passadou un peu sado vous aussi
vous aimez bien faire mal vous êtes pour
nous ils ont regardé les cassettes
pornos à d'abord question non mais ça
existe pas beaucoup les femmes je crois
je crois que les hommes regardent
prenant saisir au mac c'est vrai ça je
crois que ça me nourrit une relation
l'acte sexuel du film est comme ça cru
qui les excite et les femmes ça n'existe
pas c'est à dire la tristesse qui a
trouvé plus que le plaisir station enfin
le tournoi
toi mais c'est triste quand l'histoire
finit mal sans jouer les prudes et tout
ça il m'est arrivé d'être excités mais à
regret ah bon oh oui ça me dit qu'il va
vous avez excité quand même oui mais
vraiment un regret quoi est-ce que vous
êtes bien non je suis pas gay sous
géronto c'est pareil gérant toffin
sûrement pas sûrement pas sûrement pas
il ya des galères que j'ai à la jambe et
au bras n'ont pas non plus mais non je
ne l'étais pas oui les sentais chez les
adolescentes aussi mejia mais on peut le
dire j'ai mes chiens désolé sont au fil
wi fétiche au j'aime bien les chaussures
les gants à l'élégance est en fait c'est
pas du tout tromper la main dans l'huile
bouillante
si les zones on joue non au monde ils
n'ont pas non plus
[Musique]
bien est-ce que vous êtes lesbo vous est
hétéro finalement je crois finalement
vous avez découvert qu'après tout c'est
tjrs hétéro mais je l'étais à la base
ouais j'ai fait un petit détour par an
nées tour de 10 ans mais c'est devenu
une parenthèse voilà et vous revenez
maintenant à l'hétérosexualité
ouais ça vous plaît mais aussi vous avez
un mec là sérieusement
ben alors lancé un appel c'est que ça
marche c'est que larusso prenons larusso
par exemple très la reçoit lancé un
appel dans cette émission n'a trouvé
injuste s'appelle fabrice il très bien
grâce à l'émission grâce à l'étude de
lancer un appel
vas-y que de moi voilà je prends de
l'âge annoncé qu'ils les égorgeurs est
ce que vous êtes tous trop c'est vrai ça
peut être être un peu trop me stresser
annonce on sortait de chez vous oui
j'étais agoraphobe et qui vous faisait
des courses et bunge à l'aise sur
trottoir d'en face il y avait une
épicerie dont je ne suis ruiné pendant
un an et je t'ai truc super cher je peux
pas sortir jusqu'à ce qu'on me dise que
que si ça continue il allait falloir
materner parce que je peux pas aller
chercher mes cigarettes et j'ai eu peur
est là
je me suis soigné tout seul tu finis
mais c'est gérable mais là ça va la
règle comment est ce que vous êtes
nympho je crois pas non c'est ça veut
dire quoi
banal l'infoman c'est une fille qui a
besoin de beaucoup d'hommes vous de
rapports sexuels journée pour le rapport
en lui même juste pour la forme où
l'acte et non non vous êtes mito non
plus ne vous êtes schizo sûrement
complètement que ça a touché l'accueil
d'un dinosaure le jeu 3par sent le mec
qui vient de toi et monfils et
dinosaures de gaston cela quand même
il vient pour la queue devant dinosaures
enfin sexy tout ça les genoux est parano
ouais bazot certainement je vais bien
qu'on fasse mal physiquement oui quand
on fait l'amour se dire qu'on vous parle
non ça dépend de la personne ne sait
rien si entre qui monte ça ne fait pas
de mal mais je passais pas besoin de ça
vous êtes gérant taux pendant gérante
aux contrats même les dieux pas jusqu'à
maintenant vous êtes zone cocody
toto
est-ce que d'amour est ce que vous êtes
à d'amour mais on ne sous estime
vachement d'amour donc vous êtes un
homme
oui je vous êtes métro boulot dodo
non vous êtes disco voit la super star
ham scott chez flammarion
pour savoir vraiment qui vous êtes on va
faire une interview siméon bouge pas
même un jingle
[Musique]
bien alors est ce que vous êtes mytho
oui skeezo oui parano oui un peu moins
mais oui bazot
non pas trop ce dos oui ça d'eau non
plus exhibo un peu oui géronto pas du
tout pédo non on sent quand même qu'un
il apparaît non parce que c'est pas
légale à berne vers parler de ma semaine
tout à leur fétiche oh non ça va adamo
non gayssot oui oui vous êtes tous
finalement non mais sérieusement non
mais tous les vices en fait gérante au
sol géronto ilan pas les vieilles ouais
non mais les vices ou là c'était
d'ailleurs dans le bouquin que vous avez
sorti sur wild lévis où la perversité
c'est en fait où elle décrivait que la
perversité c'était un mythe inventé par
les bonnes gens pour expliquer l'étrange
attraits de certains autres la
perversité lévis je pense que c'est une
façon de de passer de belles journées
quoi c'est pas forcément désagréable
je suis sûr que si on répondait tous à
ce questionnaire lloret chacun de nous
ré davis comme ça je sais pas je voulais
pas payer les gens non mais je veux dire
qui peut dire qu'il n'y a aucun vice
évidemment way et qui peut dire que
c'est un vice oui
mr bien on ne bouge pas pendant m
elle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes ma joue assez parlé vous dites
il ya quand même un certain plaisir à un
moment imaginé que je pourrais l'être en
gros wen en pis oui non il ya des
situations de quelques fois je me
demande si je ne suis pas un petit peu
là vous jouez vous répondre franchement
c'est bien parce que vous êtes sado
voilà quand vraiment bête j'imagine oui
c'est ça mais vous faites pas mal à
votre fiancée comme ça pour lui faire du
bien
j'ai paniqué je suis à un moment tout le
monde a cru vous étiez avec alexandre
jardin
mais j'essaie remet à coupon était en
vigueur n'était on est effondré qs
nicolas cru que j'étais avec des makes
rivette personne m'emmerde il n'y a pas
de problèmes qui n'ont plus bas qu'ils
n'ont plus mythos oui un peu mytho wef
ah oui ça fait du bien c'est bon il faut
un peu dans les métiers qu'on fait oui
parano paranoid beaucoup ouais et je
retiens tout les bains comme tout le
monde je crois
tous les trucs mauvais en retient puis
nous les compliments mais reste critiqué
tout ouïe où tout d'un coup on va me
dire un truc à la cour n'avait pas donné
de faire comme il est sage ce soir je
trouve est ce que vous êtes exhibo pas
pas trop là au cap d'agde a dit la
serviette et vous n'aviez bon c'est pas
trop mon truc géronto les vieux des
vieux de 51 ans est ce que je serais
qu'un mec comme vous n'ont pas trop vite
non
[Applaudissements]
en même temps et michel onfray la
nettoie je suis quarante neuf mois pas
loin quand on cherche on trouve
mais pas franchement bien est ce vous
êtes porno vous regardez des cassettes
pendent j'ai fait un truc mieux que ça
ouais c'est un scoop
j'ai doublé un film porno la fin ah ben
ouais c'est pas parce que j'avais besoin
d'argent c'est klapisch qui a réalisé un
court métrage porno et j'ai fait une des
actrices 25 gauche
je me souviens plus du tabac le texan je
passe je peux dire tout ce qu'on voulait
je vous ai dans l'oralité sur le ce pour
vous le la perversion face par l'oralité
vous avez vous aimé dire des mots un peu
fou lâché ça me dérange pas du tout j'ai
pas de problème avec ça mais c'est
dommage que je sois trop vieux pauvres
bon bah il faut qu'on inverse les rôles
c'est le gage que j'avais accepté allait
bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est marrant je me sens mieux payé là
alors qu'ils regardaient ce rebond soir
reçoit reconnaissait le principe on va
faire l'interview psy ah ouais c'est
dans ta bulle psy on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle on ne bouge pas
pendant le jean galle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu connais des questions alors su quand
on refait le djing alors à lui
maintenant alors je vais bouger je suis
baffie mois on leur fait on ne bouge pas
pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sa soeur posant de faire belle maison
mais là où tu es très con c'est que j'ai
viré pour la prochaine les chapitres
j'ai pas pensé oui tu prendras calais
olivier est con comme un comique à faire
alors est ce que tu es sado ouais j'aime
bien faire mal
j'aime bien me pincer le bout des seins
maso ouais temps en temps j'aime bien me
faire passer le bout des seins claustro
claustro non pas du tout au contraire
j'adore être pas de chaleur enfermé que
la jazz heures être enfermé tous à jouer
mythos nitoo bah oui je me prends pour
thierry ardisson donc sunnito schizo
schizo bah oui je suis quatre
personnages à la fois je suis un ami
avait écrit que j'étais à la fois que je
voulais être daniel filipacchi patrick
sabatier paul morand et finalement
j'étais un peu des trois aujourd'hui
chez un peu plus thierry ardisson parano
de moins en moins de parano mais c'est
vrai pendant des années je pensais que
tout le monde disait du mal de moi puis
un jour la profession va décerner un 7
d'or est donc depuis je sais que tout le
monde m'a d'abord l'espace jean luc expo
part dans aig dont j'aime bien balader à
poil et mes enfants me le reproche de
l'histoire à intégrer
mes enfants me le reproche à bleau
tremblements je me suis habillé une fois
en filles dans bad minuit aux bains
douches et ça m'allait pas non non
fétiche aux as
j'aime bien oui j'aime bien les petits
des petits objets des petits souvenirs
les pieds géronto gérant tour pas du
tout alors c'est marrant je suis plutôt
linverse la pédo zone non non non je
pourrais pas faire l'amour avec mon
cheval parce qu'il ya une trop grosse
[__]
ragot pardon ragots est-ce que je suis
radio à j'adore les ragots et ce à tous
les ragots sur la profession safem le
dernier à qui marche le mieux en ce
moment c'est le restaurant de jean luc
delarue qui s'appelle la redevance parce
que c'est vous qui l'avez payé
est ce que tu es sanglots sanglots ouais
je suis sanglots quand je vais voir le
film de joe louis et bacri le goût des
autres ou qu'on tombe dans nos sept d'or
chasser sanglots obispo
non non honnêtement je suis pas obispo
dans sage et plus en plus même si je
devenais obispo je me fera tant sur la
masse turbo de moins en moins mais froid
ben parce que plus tu es célèbre boîte
trabzon te masturber
est ce que tu es populo bachy populo moi
je viens du peuple donc évidemment j'ai
aucun mépris pour le peuple puisque j'en
viens on va les serbes ont peu hâtives
et regrettables à la merde c'était trop
on ne bouge pas
[Applaudissements]
bien alors si vous êtes schizo je ne
pourrais pas rester dans un film enfin
rassembler c'est à dire porter sur mes
épaules un film en tant que metteur en
scène
est ce que vous êtes parano oui oui oui
en fait je crois que je souffre de
toutes les pathologies
bon d'accord base vous dites seulement
oui alors est ce que vous êtes maso non
j'aime pas beaucoup est ce que vous êtes
sado non est ce que vous êtes seaux
d'eau est ce que vous êtes exhibo est ce
que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes nympho non géronto
ça dépend de l'âge cinquante deux ans
ces vieux 52 ans alors oui voilà eh ben
voilà
hélène de fougerolles voilà et 54 c'est
pour la ville ça va dépendre chauffant
50 cadres non ça va hein pourquoi pas
bon c'est bien quand même s'il en est
qui attend là bas qui se dit [__]
c'est pas mal quand même 52 54 à toutes
tes chances calais la confiance et on a
26 aulas maintenant je le déteste ce
type déjà je suis déjà je n'aime pas ce
truc là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous avez bougé oui je vous lis tout sur
cette émission avait pourtant je la suis
un bon rallume
non ça le rend que vous avez été
exemplaire tu toi au moins tu as été
exemplaire vous citiez
attention interview si on ne bouge pas
pendant le guignol bonne réponse de
thierry en dessous je réponds à caroline
qui n'ont rien email en disant on fait
toujours l'interview au psi à des filles
banon je la fais un garçon et c'est
beaucoup plus excitant
est ce que vous êtes parano par exemple
je vais abénex quand il a lancé son fils
me l'a dit la chasse aux beineix est
ouverte
alors tout le monde à les mélanger pas
de chasse aux beineix et personne ne l'a
vu encore donc c'est un peu de la parano
est ce que vous vous êtes un peu comme
ça à croire que tout le monde vous
déteste c'est tout non non non non je
pense pas non non non mais par rapport à
jean jacques je pense que il ya des gens
qui l'attendait au cou avec un couteau
quand même avait quand même c'est que
c'est vrai mais non je sais quelle
raison la la je pense au contraire même
qu'il a été très subtil très très
spirituel paramore d'accord à cette
phrase excuse est ce qu'ils au nom
claustro oui c'est peut-être pour ça
d'ailleurs que je ne fais pas de théâtre
ouais et
même au gymnase ces prix le gymnase
s'est pris pour trois ans je vous êtes
exhibo oui non pas trop
vous n'êtes pas exhibo non pas tant que
ça magnéto serge vous êtes nympho oui
pas forcément que jamais j'aime me
tapait beaucoup de femmes mais j'aime
bien refaire plusieurs fois oui c'est
dur assène fétiche au bape anna rothwell
attaque à chaque foyer salle au nom pas
bon non vous aimez pas homo végéter
violée à l'âge de 13 ans par un
pédophile donc avant c'est vrai j'ai du
mal
ah oui dans ce cas là je savais pas ça
mais non personne ne le savait pas
c'était aussi la première fois que je le
dis je suis sur le recul
c'est pas vrai oui c'est vrai c'est bien
c'est courageux de dire ça alors
attendez parce que si nous applaudissent
et trop ça va encourager les p2p en même
temps ces courageuses qui fait et il se
passera d'oser quoi voulez qu'on arrête
là parce que non pourquoi non têtards
d'eau oui ça m'arrive
ouais c'est honteux comment peux tu mon
coco non ayrault non adamo oui mais
enfin il ya bien longtemps
bernardo 2-0 sur mu est bonne à dos ou
bien est-ce que vous êtes disco non jean
hugues anglade
avec les mêmes ne bouge pas on en
meeting
[Musique]
bien j'ai bougé il a bougé non charlotte
je bougeais obliger leurs enfants à
l'école est ce que vous êtes charlotte
rampling est ce que vous êtes
mythos je dois pas être parce que je
connais pas le mot est ce que vous êtes
schizo un petit peu mais c'est no parano
non claustro légèrement sado non maso
non exhibo a way home au nom adamo si
vous êtes à d'amour c'est vrai ce que
vous êtes disco oui
tél
[Musique]
et voilà merci beaucoup merci sur le
carreau on n'accouche pas pendant le
single on ne bouge pas pendant le single
[Musique]
c'est l'interview psy si hockey est ce
que vous êtes mytho non non mythomane
non non j'aime bien dans le spectacle il
ya beaucoup de personnages qui sont
complètement mytho mais moi dans la vie
je suis pas je suis pas spécialement me
thonon non et je détecte souvent les les
mythomanes prend j'adore ça quand il ya
quelqu'un qui arrive commence à parler
que sa part il commence à raconter
n'importe quoi ça c'est fabuleux un têtu
détecte là où d'ailleurs tard je vous
écoute et il croit elle lui raconte
qu'il est ce que vous êtes
skeezo zizou zizou je suis skizomeuh
ouais ouais ouais ben obligatoirement
coûte quant au match comptera sur scène
mais c'est pas non plus très très loin
de ce que je suis dans la vie parano
parano complètement complètement à wayne
croyais que tout le monde vous déteste
du mal de vous non non mais je suis
parano qua non mais non mais non c'est
pas ça s'est passé avec son frère avec
son frère et son copain oh [__] peut
prendre ça donne un exemple si tout le
monde déteste je ne fais pas la paranoïa
par rapport à par rapport à ça par
exemple mais par pour plein de trucs je
fais s'il ya un bruit ou je fais je
bloque vite sur java par année au ca
voilà viens je suis pas parano je fais
c'est pas parano c'était au dessus d'une
chose qui rit j'aime pas quand dans vos
émissions vous posez la question sourire
qu'elle a déjà bien maso non vous
n'aimez pas les simples ça ça c'est bon
c'est pas pareil
c'est pas j'aime bien les ça j'aime bien
timé papa jusqu'à la douleur à datacore
justin c'est comme ça donne des petits
frissons
il est sympa c'est dommage qu'une règle
tu as elle fit bien est-ce que vous êtes
sado ça donnera non on ne va pas faire
mal
non une petite fessée de temps en temps
si bas j'ai bien aimé la petite fessée
cantal ont bien mérité une petite fessée
là je te regarde encore une fois mais
oui oui là n'était pas obligé de la
prochaine question ce n'est pas obligée
de regarder mais est-ce que vous êtes
seaux d'eau titeuf enfin franchement oui
bailly si on répond franchement bien
tout le temps mais moi je réponds tout
temps franchement dans la vie je suis
pas un passionné
ah bon je n'en sais pas non il pas non
si wayne dans un des fois quand
pour donner un petit peu de piquant
c'est à dire c'est un peu comme les
aventuriers parlant tiens j'ai parlé
dans ce pays
et oui vous êtes sur france 2 chaîne du
service public messieurs je vous êtes
exhibo bizarrement je suis assez chasse
est réservé et c'est par exemple j'aime
pas téléphoner devant des gens certains
trucs mais par contre c'est vrai que
faire faire l'amour dans d'autres
personnes
ouais ça peut être sympa d'en payer
il ya du beau monde là il ya 2 3
millions de genre est ce que vous êtes
homo ah non je vous êtes trio oui la
première fois la terreur non là mes
parents on regarde ça de votre égard me
dit l'heure d'aller chercher une bière
dans le frigo
ouais ouais est ce que vous êtes fétiche
au nom pas porno vous regardez des
cassettes pornos ça m'a passé ça sont
servis dit qu'une masse vers 12-13 ans
vous avez votre époque
ouais bah c'était les débuts par contrat
est ce que vous êtes géronto c'est quand
on se tape des gens plus vieux à
ah non non une fille de 32 ans mais bon
ouais voilà non jusqu'à 40
richard d'accord parce que jusqu'à 50 60
ça non est ce que vous êtes zoo moi je
sais pas tant des sénateurs au bout de
six mois oui oui mais c'est l'interview
qu surtout ouais y avait un cubain ya un
mec qui va envoyer un e-mail ne m'a dit
non non il ya un mec qui m'a envoyé un
e-mail pourquoi tu demande pas aux
invités quand tu fais l'interview psy
vous avez de la chance c'est pas tomber
sur vous vous avez vu et toi non plus
est ce que vous êtes nécro à non scato
et des fois ça on n'est pas uniquement
mais non jusqu'à tout par exemple la
toile aussi non pas 10 14 et est ce que
vous êtes
adamo non madame qu'est ce que tu
attends un parade amoureuse qu'on aime
adamo comme gamma d'amour oui oui alors
je refuse d'être peu de mes traces de
diana beau voilà c'était que sur le
maintien
jamais autant de la question est ce que
vous êtes adamo pendant l'acte sexuel
c'est obligatoire une fois d'amour à
fond si l'eau n'arrive pas ce week end
alors maintenant on va voir que
l'interview ci n'est pas seulement
réservé aux filles puisque vous donner
puisque vous allez en être la victime
ouais je suis jamais bon truc qui
saignait
[Musique]
il a bougé mais rallume n'est pas couché
j'ai regardé l'émission
pourquoi sa venue de fait du cheval ou
quoi les délateurs faut faire rigueur
alors que guillaume canet on va voir
maintenant que l'interview psy n'est pas
seulement réservé aux filles puisque
vous voulez en être la victime
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai mal choper le regard regarde bien
alors vous connaissez le principe est ce
que vous êtes mito quand ça m'arrange
enfin parano ouais ouais
skeezo non graves schizo ouais non non
non non mais me regarde pas comme ça
elle me l'a fait avant l'art gars
incroyable de me regarder juste un truc
faites-le pour ma femme mes enfants j'ai
de la famille s'est sentie arrêté de me
regarder voilà bien si si regardez moi
maso los masos non pas du tout ma zone
non peut-être vous avez peut-être des
fois j'aime bien me faire du mal mais
psychologiquement et physiquement
non non physiquement non non non les
bougies tout ça non non ça d'eau non non
plus - sous dos non plus exhibo ouais
ouais non non c'est vrai mais mais en
privé ouais mais c'est quand vous êtes
tout seul exemple c'est comment ma télé
géant vaudois
non non non mais avec des proches en
fait je m'en rends compte que j'aime
bien me montrer mon cul tout ça ouais
fetisov êtes fétiche au nom sait pas
très bien si ça j'aime c'est vrai le
harass l'adresse et le porno alors et
cassettes pornos vrai bah ouais bon
comme tout le monde aime bien bien sûr
j'écoutais classe est ce que vous êtes
vibro non non on va quoi vibro c'est
quoi les brosser le space mountain ça
c'est des gens qui aiment les films
utiliser des biberons ma soeur est ce
que vous êtes trio non non non non je
vais essayer si bon si vous avez un
petit souci mais les deux filles et un
garçon aux deux garçons une fille non de
finir son nom mais c'était très
longtemps mais avec ce fini tout ça
alcoolo
non non j'aime bien boire un coup comme
monde quoi non je me lève pas avec le
102 matin picardo oui est ce que vous
êtes kadéos oui mais non mais non c'est
sincèrement ils savent que j'aime
beaucoup un bon maintenant c'est gentil
ces scientifiques de taloches magazine
en les bouches pendant le jingle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien facile à l'interview que vous êtes
mito pas du tout mito est ce que vous
êtes parano totalement ah oui je prends
tout pour moi noté chez vous vous faites
de petites croix en face
est ce que vous êtes schizo non pas du
tout mazeau oiseaux way des petites
brûlures aux cigarettes temps en temps
j'aime bien défini
je vous êtes san ou pas du tout vous
n'aimez pas faire mal gérant tôt
j'aurais fait montre moi je suis pas
trop attiré sexuellement par lever en
général non janvier pedro non non pépé
d'eau exhibo et du tout vous savez à
quoi vous avez échappé au canada
j'apprends encore soif de teri polo
féticheur n'ont pas fait si chaud non
plus aux maux du co moi j'ai fait du
coup je verrai ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes corneau tu vas vous
regardez des cassettes pour nous le soir
chez vous non pas régulièrement ça va
arriver
vous êtes arrivé avec david webb en
écoutant sa chanson ding tauriac josette
vibro masseur
non pas du tout triaud non je sais que
c'est super à la mode on me l'a proposé
plusieurs fois vous avez refusé
ouais non la femme ne m'attire pas un
gigolo
d'abord il est ok la cli thonon a enlevé
avec les taureaux c'est trop forte
zelko l'eau
non je suis saoul après deux verres donc
ouais donc batardeau anciennement mais
plus anciennement mais plus coco cocoon
parti ou à la drogue
la drogue ah non pas du tout pas du tout
ça va être dur à canal alors on m'avait
prévenue mais je n'ai rien vu bien je
vous êtes héros héros de la drogue sinon
je suis pas drôle du tout vous êtes
disco avant
cheveux pendant le génial
[Musique]
bien plus cette interview psy vous
connaissez non en face vous êtes
mythomane mito impôt un peu parano
beaucoup schizo non maso un peu voilà
vous aimez bien souffrir un peu
psychologiquement ou physiquement je
vois un doux mélange des deux quand même
où il vient de passer ou mordus ça peut
arriver et ça donne ça va avec un petit
peu aussi un peu sado maso vous avez une
robe en vinyle chez vous vous êtes homo
j'ai essayé ça vous a pas plu si c'était
très excitant
ouais ça va continuer non vous êtes
vibro non je vous êtes trio nous plaît
vous avez jamais essayé non mais non la
société encore je veux bien le croire la
toute petite la petit peu à bout 1
[Applaudissements]
c'est à ces enfants ces tensions non
quand elle était petite n'acceptez pas
ce genre de chose quand elle était
petite forme appelée babouins dont vous
n'avez jamais essayé non plus ce trio
non vous avez essayé
franchement non je crois que ça doit
rester vivante asthmatiques
c'est de l'ordre du fondeur vous êtes
gérant tôt c'est à partir de quel âge
non je déconne 50 points parce que pas
du tout géronto présente notre ami avait
un seul à vous a dit terry lhermitte à
côté de vous pas du tout un imaginaire
il oeuvrait thierry lhermitte et ça
boume nom et vous les vieux n'ont pas
forcément vieux mais ont plumé roi
pétaud non à dos on n'aime pas les ados
ou non exhibo bassila ouais ouais ouais
un peu exhib haut mais chez vous aussi
ou simplement sur la scène oui chez moi
je suis tranquille ouais je suis seul il
ya des gens qui ont des voisins qui
regarde je ne me soucie pas des voisins
exhibo c'est bien ce que je dis est ce
que vous êtes fétiche oh non non pas du
tout porno vous regardez des cassettes
pornos ça peux m'amuser mais seuls des
solos peut-être solo finalement
peut-être d'infos non pas du tout pipeau
non non et disco très
tiens vous savez marcel desailly qu'on
ne bouge pas pendant le singer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est bien jugnot bien interview psy
donc si vous êtes parano un peu oui
du fait de ma profession oui un petit
peu vous avez peur que les gens disent
du mal de vous comme ça par derrière
disons que je prête beaucoup attention à
ce que j'en dise quelquefois trop quoi
en guerre de ma femme excuse et de
mégalo mito peut-être quelques fois vous
êtes schizo maso peut-être vous aimez
bien qu'on vous fasse mal attention ici
du pain c'est de se mettre du splendid
est ce que vous êtes sado vous aimez
faire mal non vous aimez faire souffrir
non cave où il devra du roz ar de kings
est ce vous être qu il a du talent mais
en fait je veux dire c est ce que vous
êtes ton monte comme nous c'est ça non
jeune trentenaire est déçu c'est normal
there are made à la place jamais déçu
déjà très très contente d'être à côté de
lui
chaque chose en son temps je vous êtes
homo non que je sache est ce que vous
êtes gros lot oui oui alors va changer
de place est ce que vous êtes trio et à
et deux et trois j'avais fait des prises
et n'ont jamais essayé même nom marcel
il faut il faut tout essayer et marcel
enfin il a peur d'avoir la barre
transversale
[Rires]
est ce que vous êtes exhibo un petit peu
mal à vue à dans leur portage sous les
douches retrouve sarthois qui triment
avec ça c'est parce que jacques chirac
c'est pour ça parce que vous êtes porno
j'ai dû avoir ma période comme tout le
monde d'avant guerre qu'est ce qui vous
arrive de chamallows jeux comme halo
jamais la chance qu'ils m'appellent
monsieur est ce que vous êtes pétards
d'eau non non dans ma profession ses
clients on a trop de contrôle des
gardiens
est ce que vous êtes adamo oui je sais
trop bien le voilà
l'homme du ce temps je pense que pour
vous une interview psi serait assez
bienvenu
on a bouge pas pendant le signal on ne
bouge pas pendant qu'ils ne bougent pas
pendant ledit guerre
[Applaudissements]
bien interview psy est ce que vous êtes
mytho j'ai peur vous soyez tous là j'ai
peur j'ai peur que vous ayez j'espère
que vous ayez une croix dans chaque cas
avec courage bah non non je veux me
faisais pas le tout mais maintenant je
suis vraiment le meilleur écrivain de
france voilà donc vers mégalo vous êtes
les galops vous le reconnaissez
non j'ai le sens de ma valeur d'accord
est ce que vous êtes parano extrêmement
mais je pense que j'ai vraiment de
bonnes raisons de l'être
pourquoi parce que tout le monde m'en
veux c'est pas du tout attends pas
graphiste est étonnant mais en tous les
cas
or tous les cas pas moi c'est gentil est
ce que vous êtes schizo bas c'était
quand je me rends compte c'est trop tard
est ce que vous êtes maso oui non vous
aimez pas souffrir non gelée était de
cliniquement 1
mais je ne suis plus quoi parce que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé
c'est très difficile à soigner est ce
que vous êtes sado depuis que je suis
plus masos chez des opportunités pour
l'être et j'essaie de résister je m'en
passe que vous êtes so do ba oui
évidemment est ce que vous êtes trop qu
enfin non malause
vous êtes gros lolos non j'aimerais pas
le dire parce que j'ai les oreilles mon
père mais machin je suis bi refoulé
c'est à dire que
voilà c'est vrai que depuis qui a le
sida comme je trouve que c'est vraiment
trop trop trop trop lourd pour moi de
couche avec une femme parce que c'est
risqué magna
j'ai plus jamais nos relations avec les
femmes
alors que s'il n'y avait pas ça je pense
que ça m'arrive de temps en temps nous
vous pourriez être gros lot en fait
ouais vieux vibro je fais ça depuis des
années triaud moi j'aime plutôt 4 et
plus géronto j'y reviens dont le sort
est avec moi exit au sens de la mode
est ce que vous êtes de sa mode est ce
que vous êtes travail en compte le temps
si vous êtes travelo non est ce que vous
êtes adamo oui complètement
on les bouge pas dans le qinghai
tu
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes mégalo oh non pas
du tout non vous êtes mito non plus
d'être parano noc schizo sauf que c'est
tout le monde est un peu sa tête un
homme enfin bon chez moi je suis un peu
de seins quand même ouais le bruit
beaucoup de défauts mais le fait d'être
si klaus est par définition un peu
schizo cyclo un peu oui oui les cyclos
luxe qu'ils ont formées maso non non pas
du tout vous n'aimez pas qu'on vous
fasse mal
oh non non non mais cherchons vraiment
alors là il ya des gens qui adorent ça
oui oui pareil oui bon alors changé j'ai
tellement con enfin bon est ce que vous
êtes ado sano non plus long mais pas
faire du mal aux doigts
moi j'ai eu pitié d'un poulet mais non
je vous êtes homo on mourra l'orne on
avait tout peut arriver
tout peut arriver tout peut arriver
vous étiez petit au maroc pourquoi vous
dites ça comme au body collet et aux
français aussi vous avez d'avoir des
propositions aux français c'est vous
dire
donc je ne me suis jamais vu en papa
août et si vous voulez que je vous dis
c'est un peu verdun de ce côté là mais
il y avait beaucoup
il y avait beaucoup de domofrance et de
gens qui avaient beaucoup de talent et
vous savez ils ont tendance à vous
féminisé et on m'avait féminisé lors
d'une tournée parce que j'étais avec eux
vous appelez la galabru non on va en
appeler parce que j'étais robert hirsch
il avait beaucoup de l'esprit il
m'appelait rosa pichon et rose à clisson
et bien vous savez on se sent un peu
femme à ce moment là c'était sait pas
aller plus loin
non non non on est resté à rosas bon est
ce que vous êtes gros lolos gros lolos à
wimbledon
ça n'a rien à voir
je suis aussi petit de l'eau je suis
lolo complet voilà c'est un corsage tous
extraordinaires et je regrette de ne pas
y avoir quoi
quoique oui est ce que vous êtes trio
trio attention et vous enfin je vais pas
être faux derche et dans mon temps à
l'époque trio j'ai goûté ouais c'est pas
mauvais la fecq deux femmes à bord avec
un nom parce que vous êtes exhibo non
pas du tout hajib ou en acteur et
toujours avec djibril cissé tarnos qui
me gêne c'est le principe de cette
interview et je comprends bien michel
galabru le gasoil à ses côtés un film on
le voit poids non c'est vrai s'il y en a
mais vous l'avez loupé j'étais figurant
dans la bataille du csb excuse et pas
sur les pompiers et ont passé des délais
comme on appelle ça le conseil de
révision
donc comme j'étais figurants on nous a
mis tous nus et moi j'ai eu le malheur
de me trouvais juste à la porte du
médecin donc pour raccorder au mal et
c'est là toute une journée tout nu avec
la script qui dotés tous les états
travelo de travaux n'ont jamais essayé
la gt gt d'acajou ford gt enfin beau
travelo et comme un
deux femmes et acteur la rue automne ya
dix devaient me rouler une pelle 1
il a refusé pourquoi il à dire me
voyante et aurore venez très bien
composé possible
est ce que vous êtes trop con rocco et
ses frères encore que ces frais d un
rocco siffredi rocco siffredi ouais
qu'est-ce que je connaissais pas rocco
siffredi non vous connaissez pas encore
cette réunion puisque il prie de
m'excuser mais je suis japonais à la
campagne non
qu'est ce que c'est rocco siffredi sait
pas se taper un poney à défrayer un peu
tout
c'est un type les montées comme un âne
allons allons non non non j'ai pas de
détails vous dire mais c'est pas rocco
ses parts au coccyx poko assez pour
cause
est ce que vous êtes
adamo ah j'adore a d'abord est ce que
vous êtes disco au melon c'est plus de
mon âge je crois va essayer
[Musique]
chalgham raconte dit mais j'ai besoin
marion alors pour évaluer votre vraie
personnalité on va vous faire une
interview psy vous êtes prête en a
bouffé ans dans la jungle
[Musique]
merci nadine je trouve extraordinaire je
suis le parcours
voilà nadine de rothschild je comprends
pourquoi elles vont vous à pourquoi ça
s'est si bien passée avec edmond pendant
ces trente sept ans c'est à dire vous
êtes la femme idéale je joue mise en
guinée merci voilà et frédéric ideas
sedan soumises ya une connotation
péjorative que j'ai franchement je
n'apprécie pas obéissance disons
frédéric ne vous mentez pas insultants
envers la baronne du tout bien frédéric
vous êtes prête à l'interview psy c'est
facile est ce que vous êtes mito non
mégalo
pas vraiment non plus paranos parano
quand j'ai un peu bu ou quand j'ai un
peu fumé j'aime pas que vos émissions où
poser la question sur le cabanis
d'accord d'accord hervé il faut parler
un peu de josé cabanis on parle jamais
de prix renaudot en 66 né en 1922 à
toulouse josé cabanis l'auteur de l'âge
ingrat
voilà c'est vrai nom n'en parle jamais
marron par semaine
pourquoi guerre des boers je refuse
qu'on parle de ce grand monsieur ses 24
je sais pas vous êtes schizo schizo je
pense pas non bazot mais the way a pesé
mais qu'on vous fasse mal non j'aime pas
je me fais moi même
ah ouais donc ça suffit toi je voulais
tenter un truc est ce que vous aimez
faire mal c'est un peu sado non pas du
tout non vous êtes homo un peu eva par
rapport à ce qu'on disait toi vous avez
échappé dans mamma lente et molle je
vous en remercie mille fois oui moi je
vais vous dire moi j'ai l'impression ça
c'est mon avis personnel mais j'ai
l'impression que toutes les filles sont
un peu même celle qui se lève ou pas je
crois que pour un mec sait plus
mais après l'émission s'est réjoui m
juste
[Musique]
moi je reste tranquille bien nantis ne
l'est pas non c'est pas non est ce que
vous êtes trio ça peut jamais dire
jamais juge que je le dis en somme un
bébé va-t-il s'en remettre je ne suis
pas sûr
est-ce que par un mot vous iriez dans
des boîtes échangistes tous les samedis
soirs vous aurait répondu quoi tous les
samedis soirs non un samedi sur deux non
même un samedi sur deux samedis par mois
non je dirais si l'histoire tirée une
expérience de temps en temps why not
pourquoi pas français baghi je te
félicite d'affilée beaucoup mieux que
toi
vous êtes exhibo quelque part on est un
peu puisque on passe à la téloche
enfin vous balader à poil devant votre
fenêtre pour les voisins et tout ça ça
vous fait passer l'info l'info non non
mais non mais non non non non non vous
aimez bien ça mais vous n'êtes pas
d'infos dire j'aime l'amour mais jules
non j'ai pas la fin au point d'être
nymphomane voilà ça a tout l'air non
voilées freiner la nymphomane qui est en
vous voilà ce que vous êtes vibro un
vibro de temps en temps un oh là là là
est ce que vous êtes porno vous regardez
des cassettes pornos marseille je trouve
ça super bidon naze quoi ah ben on a
vraiment changé
je lance un appel trouver un réalisateur
qui sache faire un film porno bien un
truc qu'excitant sympa vrai je sais pas
ce que ça c'est grenade quoi les nanas
qui sont là qui gémissent cie perfo
voilà on sera l usine on secoure quoi
vraiment je comprends que quelque part
c'est ça excite plus de gens de regarder
des reality truc c'est vrai quelque part
entre loft story un film de marc dorcel
vous choisissez quoi au nom love story
c'est vraiment trop elle se passe pas
grand chose
non mais je dirais que je sais pas à la
cassette qui s'est vendue sous le bras
de pamela anderson dont un voyage d'une
chambre ça doit être sympa
voilà je pense que ça n'a pas l'air
américaine
c'est quand même plus sympa que virginie
pour de vergy connaît cergy connaît mais
c'est laetitia là nous contacter serge
il faut s'intéresser mst maman c'est que
tu tournes dernière question est la plus
importante d'une certaine façon est ce
que vous êtes adamo à damas non c'est
pas vrai c'était avant alors qu'ils
regardaient ce rebond soir soit
reconnaissait le principe on va faire
l'interview psy ah ouais c'est
l'interruption
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
reste à présent de faire belle maison
mais là où tu es très con c'est que j'ai
admiré pour la prochaine les chapitres
j'ai pas pensé oui tu prendras calais
olivier est con comme un comique à faire
alors est ce que tu es sado ouais j'aime
bien faire mal
j'aime bien le pain c'est le bout des
seins maso ouais temps en temps j'aime
bien me faire passer le bout des seins
claustro claustro non pas du tout au
contraire j'adore être pas de salon
enfermé que la jazz heures être enfermé
tous à jouer mytho mythomane oui je me
prends pour thierry ardisson donc
chinito schizo schizo bah oui je suis
quatre personnages à la fois je suis un
ami avait écrit que j'étais à la fois
que je voulais être daniel filipacchi
patrick sabatier paul morand et
finalement j'étais un peu des trois
aujourd'hui chez un peu plus thierry
ardisson parano de moins en moins parano
mais c'est vrai pendant des années je
pensais que tout le monde disait du mal
de moi puis un jour la profession va
décerner un 7 d'or est donc depuis je
sais que tout le monde m'a d'or n'est ce
pas jean luc expo parlant et guigou
j'aime bien balader à poil et mes
enfants me le reproche déjà dispo pour
un tué mes enfants me le reproche à
blanc [__] le mans je me suis habillé
une fois en filles dans bad minuit aux
bains douches et ça m'allait pas non non
fétiche aux as
j'aime bien oui j'aime bien les petits
objets les petits souvenirs les pieds au
zoo non non non je pourrais pas faire
l'amour avec mon cheval parce qu'il ya
une trop grosse [__]
ragot pardon ragots est-ce que je suis à
goa j'adore les ragots et ce à tous les
ragots sur la profession safem le
dernier qui marche le mieux en ce moment
c'est le restaurant de jean luc delarue
qui s'appelle la redevance parce que
c'est vous qui l'avez payé
est ce que tu es sanglots sanglots ouais
bah je suis sanglots quand je vais voir
le film de joe louis et bacri le goût
des autres ou qu'on tombe de nos sept
d'or chasser sanglots masse turbo de
mois en mois mais voit pas parce que
plus tu es célèbre one of the most
urbain est ce que tu es populo je suis
populo moi je viens du peuple donc
évidemment j'ai aucun mépris pour le pas
puisque j'en viens on va les serbes
vous savez qu on ne bouge pas
vous avez bougé je sais on peut rallumer
non c'est bon mangez pas moi je connais
pas l'histoire
[Applaudissements]
j'entends bien invité jean-claude à côté
de vous on était voulait aller alors ne
bouge cadre de l'attention
didier on ne bouge pas pendant qu'on ne
bouge pas pendant le single on ne bouge
pas pendant le single via alors est ce
que vous êtes
jean claude van damme est ce que vous
êtes mito me thonon est ce que vous êtes
mégalo mais faut une tête gonflée pour
avoir pour booster son ego parce que ce
fait part de notre dans la nature
humaine
si on n'est pas qu'on est bien dans la
vie si on dit qu'on est petit
qu'est ce qu'on a envie on va rester
petit je suis grand je suis forgé
bauchet manable
[Applaudissements]
miss france
le droit parce que là est ce que vous
êtes
est ce que vous êtes malin est ce que
vous êtes parano par un an seulement
quand tu prends là un d'accord parce que
vous êtes cyclo sic non c'est tout
chimique cyclothymique ça à voir avec la
musique l'air d'être un jour comme si un
jour comme ça un jour femmes et enfants
non un jour un point que jo d'armes
est ce que vous êtes cyclo pour lui on a
tous deux pilotes mais il faut pas faire
attention à ces choses là parce que si
on fait attention à ces mots on devient
esclave des mots on devient esclave les
médicaments alors tous ces grosses gros
groupes phares asiatiques ils font du
fonds des billes under
donc on est tous normal on allait jouer
les durs ces hauts et bas il ya le
soleil à la pluie alors est des jours où
on est on est pas on n'est pas au rendez
vous est maso à on aime tous avoir mal
est ce que vous êtes sado non sado-maso
cyclo mcclure
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes trio trio c'est
quoi ça mon business on a trouvé l'amour
1 dans l'amour mais c'est comme l'amour
d'accord parce qu'être avoir des
partenaires c'est être amoureux des
vrais partenaires dans le business des
mecs qui se tient de back to back
parce que moi j'ai connu ça quand j'ai
fait le coq si l'on met dans la merde
tous mes avocats mes agents mes amis ils
sont partis à personne qui me chercher à
l'hôpital ok alors j'ai dû raser la tête
maintenant j'ai trouvé des gens solides
d'accord ok donc il faudrait déjà
emparée des gens qui ont des problèmes
dans la vie qui ont connu vos histoires
et mon histoire et des gens comme ça ils
savent que s'ils savent que l'on peut
pas accuser quelqu'un qui était pas ce
que sont les grandes idées mais on est
grand didier honnête par estrada comme
acheter
est ce que vous en pensez ce que vous
êtes j'aime quand on assiste en
délicieux je suis soit 100 millions est
ce que vous vous êtes homo un homo on
est tous au monde répulsion monde il ya
un homosexuel et à l'oeil à leurs
homologues masculins on s'adore moi je
me regarde dans la glace pour quoi pour
avoir un beau corps au caire l'on m'a
donnée aux mains d'un accord et j'essaie
de respecter le mieux que je peux alors
j'aime mon corps est ce que je suis homo
moi j'ai pas alors quand je vois un
homme dans une douche qui a un beau
corps du jeune abou course mais là je
suis homo non je crois pas mais j'aime
bien les belles choses
j'aime bien les belles femmes les
beaux-arts où j'aime bien aller les gens
qui sont intelligents où les jeunes même
d'être des nains qui ont qui savent bien
à plaindre
donc j'aime les gens
mais en fait ils sont connus est ce que
vous êtes travelo annoncé mais pas des
travaux non c'est pas ça non mais mais
ça ça m'intéresse pas de me mabille en
femme parce que c'est un peu trop
difficile quand on s'assied pour fermer
les jambes il faut des croisés c'est une
autre femme
enfin moi je prends pas des femmes parce
que moi je viens des femmes ok ce qu'ils
m'ont fait alors les hommes du jour la
femme ceci la femme cela est la femme
dit l'homme social cela est en vérité
celle qu'il a fait et lui il se plaint
dès lors il ya un problème avec ça fait
maintenant en 2001 les guerres on répète
les mêmes qu'hier toujours on est
toujours au jardin d'enfants alors je
trouve qu'un homme et une femme
devraient un peu plus on s'entendre un
homme doit être sensible comme une femme
est une femme sorte comme un homme comme
ça ils ont les deux qualités ensemble ça
fait line gaming et ça fait un couple
sur moi et ma femme c'est aux gens qu'on
mandate pour son film
bien alors sergi lopez faute de vous
mettre à poil on va vous mettre à poil
psychiquement
on va faire une interview psy vous êtes
prêt en bouche
ouais
[Musique]
non cergy vous avez bougé par notre
gueule quoi vous avez bougé on rallume
serge au bout j'ai ça je m'en fous mais
comme son combat le temps si vous ne
veut pas bouger ne vous juge pas tu te
lances et d'amuser les carpettes
je vais me bouger voilà attention
[Musique]
bien c'est des connards bien attention
interview psy sergi lopez est ce que
vous êtes mytho non non c'est à dire si
j'ai beaucoup des mythes ça se trouve il
y aura plein de mon gilet votre gestion
mythomane
non du tout est ce que vous êtes mégalo
non non parano non schizo non non non
gardé c'est pas dit qu'il disait que la
schizophrénie c'était en fait avoir que
deux personnalités
oui quand on a plusieurs groupes les
plus exquises est ce que vous êtes
narciso a c'est à dire jamais trouve
comme comme personne ne sait si je
connaissais déjà je crois que si je suis
quelqu'un qui me ferait bien mais je me
connais quand même que vous le trouvez
bien le buzz à cergy non messieurs car
super mignon il est très content
vous aimez bien côté un peu grossi côté
un peu de dieu comme ça
[Applaudissements]
avez vous la concurrence sur ses
plateaux c'est peut-être est-ce que vous
êtes sadow a des fois vous aimez bien
faire mal je sens les bandes du moment
il ya des petites douleurs qui peut être
super sympathique vous êtes mazouz que
vous aimez avoir mal ah non
les vendeurs sont sympathiques ont
séduit qui les offrent voilà comme il
n'est pas un oiseau est ce que vous êtes
exhibo non spécialement non je vois pas
on dit que tous les acteurs ont un côté
comme ça peut-être est-ce que vous êtes
gros lot ouais
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes trio trois fois le
numéro pas du gard ces deux demandes
n'ont pas de limites
non je dirais pas de numéro
1 c'est bien aussi quand vous faites
l'amour à trois
c'est une vue de l'esprit mais si vous
deviez faire l'amour à trois ou peut
faire varier le fer avec deux hommes ou
deux femmes des questions quand même
assez intime je trouve
parce que avec deux femmes vous êtes
sincère la cij a priori gsm est ce que
vous êtes homo non pas pour l'instant
ces gamins n'ont pas pour maintenant
c'est vrai mais c'était moi les choix
sexuel c'est pas vrai des homosexuels
ouais c'est vrai ya des gens qui aiment
brenneke qu'il y avait là qui me
ramasser vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai mais mais en même temps je
comprends bien aussi comme vous aimez
tout à la fois je suis déçu pour
l'instant était roi est ce que vous êtes
travelo a des fois un beau des fois
c'est des fois que ça m'arrive donnée
déguisée en femme
oui d'accord mais ce que vous allez
faire l'amour et des [__] enfin pas
très souvent non non non
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes plus tarder au
pétard dont ckoi pétards dans sa forme
natalia
est ce que vous êtes adamou excusez moi
est ce que vous êtes admis adam ont
alors qu'ils se dire oui j'ai dit non
c'est quoi ça j'ai peur j'ai peur
art
[Applaudissements]
et voilà je
la graisse humaine
à une phantom
[Musique]
langage
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je m'étais préparé pour l'interview
première fois je suis imprévisible quand
même que les gens qui venaient ici pour
la première fois une interview première
fois en un an mais ce que je sais c'est
que jean d'ormesson pareil s'était
préparé pour des interviews et des
préservatifs des machins des j'ai fait
le questionnaire de proust et des fautes
de français heureusement qu'ils avaient
déjà mail pour l'aider à faire des
fautes de français
est ce que cette mito pas du tout la
soul est mégalo ah oui oui je m'adore de
parano schizo je me suis oui oui un jour
je suppute un jour je suis sage un jour
fut studieuse joue à l'accord vous êtes
nympho par périodes sûr que peut faire 6
mois un temps six mois rien du tout elle
est ce qu'ils allaient bien schizo ces
ados alors pas encore est ce que vous
êtes maso non pas du tout
gérante au sais quoi je retrouve ce que
l'on aime les vieux à jusqu'à quel âge
ça marche cette question 50 dans 51
cependant je barre
je n'aime pas les jeunes voilà très bien
ça tombe bien ouais t'as les bonbons
bruno bonbons pour moi est ce que vous
êtes vibro c1 librement non c'est un
téléphone portable
on leur en faire un pour mes 25 ans a
alors à l'essayer alors essayez tout
seul ouais on en fait ça vibre mal ouais
parce que ça fait au mieux un mec bien
bah oui courau catherine me dit cabanon
elle est coachée calé dans un trip hyper
romantique qu en ce moment un jeu
pendant la productrice de l'émission
qu'est ce que l'on s'étonne que vous
n'avez jamais essayé à ce que je suis
vraiment désolé je m'excuse est ce que
vous êtes homo my way la prusse hilarant
comment sais tu avais côté entre ce
qu'il dit c'est ça
cette observation est ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes est ce que vous
êtes homo pour ben oui non j'ai fait de
fait cet été
ouais c'est au tout ouais ça vous a pas
suffisamment plu pour continuer à sanaa
puis à mais je préfère les armes
d'accord vous êtes trio là c'était de
suivi par exemple à bonitas alors j'ai
que ce fantasme de vendée des gens mes
coups ça tombe bien de bien du monde ce
soir
est ce que vous êtes
rocco c'est pas l'attaquer change
ah bon non alors philips pioneer vous
n'êtes pas au bout de vos peines et vous
allez avoir un traitement que je réserve
d'habitude à de très jeunes filles
pendant l'été
[Applaudissements]
bien fantastique philippe sollers
oui interview si oui est-ce que vous
êtes mytho non je connais trop les
mythes pour être biteau est ce que vous
êtes mégalo je connais trop toutes les
fontes des ressorts de la mégalomanie
pour être vraiment mégalo mais je
comprends la mégalomanie
l'artiste doit être mégalomane mais si
vous êtes parano oui bien sûr comme vous
comme tout le monde comme chacun le
problème est de justifier sa paranoïa et
le problème est là c'est à dire que en
effet toute singularité tout ce qui se
distingue est automatiquement persécutés
donc il faut être parmi les paranoïaques
ont des vrais ennemis aussi des fois oui
c'est vrai non mais c'est bâtissons ça
c'est une phrase de parano ce bateau est
mêlée derrière nous et des foyers d
ailleurs thierry thierry le renard ouais
en plus il est imité
il était leur marque et a toujours voté
oui oui oui
les pensionnaires des fonctionnaires
défaut d'avis en gentil les invités
chaque semaine y en a un qui me dit mais
pourquoi votre émission est tellement
copie est ce que vous êtes maso
ça dépend avec la personne qui
trouveraient agréable que je le sois un
lit de s'il est ce que vous êtes
s'il a bien mais qu'est ce qu'il a est
ce que vous êtes sad au château ce
adorable les pandas personne qui serait
un contente que tout dépend des goûts de
l'autre oui docile bien est-ce que vous
êtes sous dos ça dépend de la personne
accès ce dominant et c'est très bien
c'est clair est-ce qu'ils étaient djibo
a exhibé comme chirac qui se met à poil
à brégançon non écoutez écoutez chirac
fait franchement je vois pas pourquoi
vous nous comparez ce personnage est ce
que tout à l'heure ils auront fait
michel leeb dans le taxi à côté écouter
celle d'un taxi est ce que vous êtes
gigolo j golo est-ce que vous avez été
gigolo étant jeune oh oui
vous étiez des vieilles pour de l'argent
au nom des jeunes pendant à wii fit ça
c'est plutôt est ce que vous êtes gros
lolos rhône non pas du tout ah bon ah
non ça tombe bien aussi
est ce que vous êtes trio deux femmes un
homme alors la rédac à ils sont tous
pareils mais ça arrive ça plaise ça
arrive que ça plaît bien sûr ça peut
plaire
est ce que vous êtes
est ce que vous êtes au zoo animaux
imaginairement oui oui oui
non mais dans le discours oui mais pas
vrai non je suis ton chien ton change
ton zèbre est ce que vous êtes rocco au
paso voilà donc ce mystérieux mozart
c'est aux éditions plon on ne bouge pas
voir jean galle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas gérard hier qui a préparé les
questions non mais il aurait pu bon
attention alors est ce que vous êtes
mytho non non non vraiment pas n'en a
pas du tout est ce que vous êtes mégalo
je pense un peu tous les gens qui font
ce métier me sens un peu
ouais mais pas plus que ça mais ap un
parano ah oui ça sûrement ouais c'est
pareil on est tous un peu parano non ce
métier on a raison parce que les paranos
ont aussi détruit
si vous êtes schizo non pas du tout non
non vraiment y'a pas de laurent et non
non non je crois pas que je suis même
partout j'ai l'impression vous êtes
nympho non plus
les deux ados non je pense je suis
plutôt maso vous êtes exhibo pas du tout
alors là vraiment ce n'est sûrement pas
je vais pas comme lui qui se dit sap sur
les courts et tout s'annonce sera
incapable de faire ce qu'il a fait est
là on a vraiment moi je serais capable
de le refaire
non vous êtes drôle que ça veut dire
goaler une grosse poitrine est ce que ça
veut dire non non non non non non non
non d'ailleurs je préfère les femmes à
petites poitrines genre jane birkin par
exemple que fait le winter italia qui ça
thalia à jouer la jeune fille qui
l'avait pas remarqué en fait si vous
êtes trio passé souvent
ce que vous êtes travelo non pas du tout
a annoncé aux branches va pas c'est pas
mon truc la lettre masturbe au pardon
masturbe vous êtes plus tarder au pétard
doba écoutez je l'étais pas j'ai
rencontré un type en noir qui fait de la
com et ça m'arrive oui de fumée comment
il dit à bourges du jem quelques jours
thierry gêne pas comment vos émissions
vous poser la question sur le cap à nice
d'accord mais on arrête
voilà mais il faut pas que je bosse
après quoi ouais c'est vraiment vous
fumez jamais puisque vous blesser tout
le temps si par exemple la après
l'émission si vous offrez un pétage de
fumée venant tier 1
d'ailleurs je crois bien que une des
dernières fois où j'en ai fumé c'est ici
avec pierre paul jacques qui était
invité
ces deux émissions pour
le pire est à venir tina arena nous
allons faire une interview psy on ne
bouge pas pendant le kenya
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
- est-ce que traductrice 100 sur le coup
ouais sur le coup bien sûr qu'on est sur
le coup belinda pas d'allusion comme ça
parce qu'après ça me chauffer tu sais
comment ça se termine
et oui malheureusement tina est ce que
vous êtes mytho j'ai menti dans ma vie
mais je suis pas une menteuse
est ce que vous êtes mégalo est ce que
vous êtes parano affiché méritions et cs
madrid rejoint oui peut-être
vous savez que françois bayroux qui va
être président de la république
française en 2002 et contre le pétard je
vais vous dire une chose qui arrive
j'aime pas qu'on prenne nos émissions
vous poser la question sur le cabanis
hockey avaient été levées est ce que
vous êtes schizo est ce que vous êtes
cyclo certain moment je peux l'être
est ce que vous êtes l'info je ne sais
pas mais j'aime bien faire l'amour oui
ça c'est sûr oui oui tout à fait
[Musique]
certaines chansons de une nouvelle
fiancée dans ses aventures avec des
hommes
justement la presse tu me rassures est
ce que vous êtes maso non yes non oui
oui je me suis un peu oui
ah c'est pour pas d'hier mais d'une
manière un peu plus modérée sans vous
sabotez c'est à dire la sienne oui elles
répondent qu'elles traduisent qu'elle
réponde pas pour elle à sziget merci est
ce que vous êtes sado non
bon c'est une perte de l'émotion qu'on
peut avoir un truc je vais en profiter
est-ce qu'on peut être des deux en fait
parce que je sais très beau écologique
ça tu peux avoir ma soeur m'a aimé avoir
mal s'est passé colonial vous êtes sado
maso moi je fais tout que cadière
[Applaudissements]
tina arena est ce que vous êtes trio non
ménages à toi non non non je profite
juste du de personnes s'est mieux passé
c'est beaucoup et c'est passionnant
ça c'est à ces deux textes pas belinda
est ce que vous êtes porno annoncé
qu'elle allait pas particulièrement je
trouve qu'en fait ça pour beaucoup de
goût tout ça mais peut-être que j'ai pas
regardé en profondeur 1 le porno chic
par exemple en général quand on regarde
tu atterris peut-être oui c'était la
maison
dernière question tina arena est ce que
vous êtes lesbo est-ce que vous avez
déjà essayé les [__] m'avait appelé
non
[Applaudissements]
tina
je suis
voilà
[Musique]
un chant fort interview psy est ce que
vous êtes mito non pour faut répondre à
l'envers alors non pour répondre à
l'endroit dit exactement la vérité est
ce que vous êtes mégalo par moments
certainement oui c'est important de
temps en temps sinon on tente rien quoi
je faut il faut il faut se donner un peu
des buts des choses quand même un peu
improbable va lui être parano par
périodes oui aussi elle vous plaît ça
ludivine les mecs qui doute qui sont un
peu fragiles comme ça vous préférez les
mecs qui croit dur comme fer en ce
qu'ils sont et en ce qu'ils font c'est
pas ya besoin des deux moi j'aime bien
avoir le pouvoir de rassurer pour que
moi ça me plaît les doutes
toi tu t'en fous tu vois tu pas que
jamais nos médias je faisais déjà que
vous n'êtes pas trop parano bout ça va
vous avez pas besoin de problèmes mais
quand il ya doute y a pas doute
ouais donc ça il ne faut pas aller par
là c'est tout le doute s'est c'est un
luxe le doute je suis pas un artiste
c'est pas un être sensible et délicat
nos muscles
séguin cela limite nalco se tasser à
votre juste assez comme on va vendre le
marron va faire un jeu du homard tient
parce que le mari par ce soir c'est
comment s'est mise en scène
il suffit de tomber en même temps
mettez-vous comme salle v nord les mains
comme ça aussi il faut cogner à la porte
ah ah
attention
bene
[Musique]
adieu
bon
j'ai acheté
profit de michaël blanc par un garçon
qui savait lui-même d'ailleurs omar il a
acheté nomades on se marie le pen
cinquante mille balles et les cinquante
mille balles iront à michaël blanc qui
est emprisonné à ben ali voilà merci
omar
attention est ce que vous êtes maso vous
avez quand vous faites ce matin
non c'est pas je n'aime pas avoir mal
mais je me suis aperçu que souvent
jambes et un an site des situations qui
n'étaient pas forcément à mon avantage
c'est que j'y trouvais certainement un
certain plaisir que je vous pose même
pas la question veut pas maso totalement
maso avant mais je leur en ai dans mon
expression picturale à mes temps libres
à 6,6
saad ont mesuré d'une manière mesurée
quoi vous êtes sûrs d'au nom sympa pas
encore juste après ça do est ce que
cette église bondée nous balader à poil
devant les fenêtres
l'enclavé est récent passage dont vous
êtes gros lolos bas pendant ce moment là
était mannequinat est clair donc elle
est très grands comme ça très élancée
mais c'est pas très gros lolos c'est
vrai le gros lot
je pense qu'il faut la refaire
est ce que vous êtes trio
non papa oui c'est arrivé mais bon je
suis pas là en ce moment je suis
patriote quoi je pose pas la question
non j'ai bien avec vous ayez compris que
tous vos questions à la con vous les
garder pour l'autre côté d'accord
une question qui peut vous intéresser la
malaisie est ce que vous êtes trop quo
c'est-à-dire comparaison et freddie
malheureusement non vous êtes chamallow
alors jean mallot expliquez-moi okuyama
le foia paille a pas d'intermédiaire
situation il ya hélas fort
et maintenant mesdames et messieurs
voici le moment que toute la france
attend c'est l'interview psid hélène
ségara
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes en ce moment c'est
tout simplement parce que vous êtes
maniaco non au grand désespoir de
beaucoup et pdt du désordre
ouais c'est vrai que tu changes non ce
métrage allemand semble est ce que vous
êtes mytho j'aime pas ça non non mégalo
pas assez va au bout de certains moi je
suis piccolo sans déranger 1
ça fait maintenant vingt minutes que
j'attends mon verre cette bonne santé
puisque vous êtes parano c'est non mais
c'est un combat dans ce métier je venais
de schizo non pas du tout vous êtes
cyclo j'ai plutôt des lommois attention
enfin parlons pas de vélo c'est ce qui
se passe quand tu entends très bien est
ce que vous êtes
l'info non non je mais par amour on peut
le devenir d'un faux mais je joue non je
suis pas d'infos et quoi maso maso et
par amour aussi on peut le devenir
non je suis pas maso comme un petit peu
ne m'attendais pas m'attacher fouetter
mais un petit peu mal un petit pincement
comme ça tout du tout mais peut-être
sauf pour exceptionnellement pour venir
ici ce soir
est ce que vous êtes sado vous aimez
faire mal a pas du tout mais pour une
[__] est que ce soir je vais devenir un
exhibo vie nous balader à poil
d'autres études au moins à très peu
d'eau bon je m'en doit si vous êtes pédo
parce qu'avec damien c'était un petit
peu de la poursuite d'un pédo du toucher
[Applaudissements]
mon fils que je suis trop maman pour
être bien qu eto o est ce que vous êtes
gigolo un nom mais si autre histoire
si je le suis je le fus se fût
inconscient mal d'accord je m'en bat
vous êtes vibro non non est ce que vous
êtes lesbo non non mais j'ai mes garçons
aux cheveux longs donc fait qu'il ya
quelque chose à creuser vrai musée
délégation félin aux cheveux loin c'est
vrai ça est ce que vous êtes pétards
d'eau si jamais fumé un pétard
j'en suis super fier parce que je peux
dire que la grand mère ma grand mère
avec ma mère qui m'ont éduqué m'ont pas
éduqué pour rire je suis très heureuse
comme ça
tiens je vais dire un truc pardon au
sujet des pétards on parle souvent de
pétards dans cette émission le pieters
pas plus grave qu'un verre de whisky en
revanche est vrai en revanche il ya
maintenant des produits qui viennent
d'amsterdam qui sont enrichis en thc et
qui sont très dangereux était haché le
thc c'est le principe qui défonce dans
le dans le chic quoi situer
ils sont enrichis d'une façon
scientifique et tu veux et ça faut
vraiment faire gaffe voilà je vais dire
si moi par exemple j'ai mes petits mais
petit gré main mais petit héros
demanderai fume un peu le bordel et à
coup ils me disent tiens venant ici je
suis pop je suis pas tellement ça
c'était chez pas quoi je te jure que
j'ai dans ma chambre d'hôtel j'ai fait
une taffe comme ça et je dis bon bah je
vais me coucher je suis rentré à la
chambre d'hôtel j'avais la télécommande
comme ça je voyais à la télé jeter dans
la télé
impossible de zapper je regardais un
truc lamentable à la télé comme ça
c'était avant le passé impossible de
mettre les couvertures sur moi j'ai été
gelés comme ça je suis resté deux heures
à cauchemars invraisemblable est ce que
vous êtes sanglots oui mais là je sais
je sais un petit peu où vous voulez en
venir c'est que c'est vrai que je pleure
facilement mais non chez motive mais par
contre comme je suis pudique je
pleurerais en public je peux pleurer que
de joies mes chagrins je les montrerai
jamais est ce que vous êtes
orlando ah oui sur l'endos le jour je
serai plus ça sera peut-être la fin mais
je suis orlando j'ai même dit que le
jour où il a en outre tué hélène
alors on va voir maintenant larry hagman
comment va votre santé mentale
on va faire une interview psy dans la
bouche d'un parlement ne bouge pas
pendant le djing aller retour de couche
tard le cauchemar prendre le bain fils
me va jacques galvani ce métro est un
souci avec le béatrice mme arrêter ben
fist très bien c'est pas bien ça mais
très bien aller on n'a pas l'habitude de
prendre les mooschois alors attention
larry est ce que vous êtes mythologie
magie n'a jamais joué dans dallas là
c'est pas lui est ce que vous êtes
mégalo yash oui parano non est ce que
vous êtes schizo mais je mélange mais
les acteurs font tout ça bonjour vous
êtes d'accord
mais ces gens qui vous êtes bien est-ce
que vous êtes un faux nom y est pas
encore a est ce que vous êtes maso non
j'aime pas la douleur
sadow nador la guerre j'aime pas faire
donner de la douleur est ce que vous
êtes seaux d'eau
non
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes gros lolos bien que
non je parle de ses coûts de ces gourous
pardon est ce que vous êtes trio mais ça
les amuse on a bon dos vous êtes à paris
là paris paris si je suis le seul mec
est ce que vous êtes homo non lieu on a
plein de trucs à faire encore est ce que
vous êtes au volant est encore très flou
[Rires]
larry est ce que vous êtes
rocco ou chamallows d'un traducteur de
geek j'ai trop connu
c'est une star du porno en france c'est
vrai hu que tu t'emmerdes les deux mois
l'écran qui ressemble alors à kent voilà
pourquoi pas is like us ce qu'il faut
c'est bien me font écran
monsieur
mémoire pitoyable
dernier aussi mesdames messieurs
[Applaudissements]
est ce que vous êtes mytho non si vous
êtes mégalo oui si vous êtes parano non
est ce que vous êtes schizo non parce
que vous êtes cyclo non je vous êtes
nympho je vous êtes maso oui je vous ai
tous à dos parce que je suis censé
développer les réponses m'expédie en 1
minute je ne dis pas ça après un petit
peu calvo dans l'ain qui tarde un peu
trop qui va jeter sa gourme jeunes en
étaient à un stade au oui vous répondiez
non ah bon mais pas moi
non non est ce que vous êtes exhibe au
nom des trios vous êtes homo non zoo a
fait pas mal de blur est ce que vous
êtes prêts pour une interview psy
vous êtes désespérant michel film qu'est
ce que vous êtes mito un petit peu
mégalo énormément la définition on peut
pas l'être un peu parano en septembre
dernier peut-être un petit peu et c'est
sympa c'est bien pété les plombs vite
maso ça dépend avec qui
mais ça vous déplaît pas
rien de ce qui est humain ne m'est
étranger ouais c'est ça dos alors même
réponse il est so do so do vous
l'écrivez comment parce que si c'est
pour avoir un peu d'eau dans la gueule
quand on fait chaud lui voler ses seaux
d'eau l'été xibaut j'aimerais j'aimerais
bien être suffisamment bons pour trouver
du plaisir à des gens qui matent mais
j'ai renoncé à cette illusion et êtes
vibro ça peut arriver ouais gros lolos
oui vous êtes trio oui elle était sûre
avec lui et soit trop c'est une course
lente au public les eaux je vous en prie
je me disais plus tôt
rocco ou chamallows f leymarie d'être
chamallows après avoir été rocco
générique
il ya longtemps que je vous attends dans
cette émission pour une interview psy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
est ce que vous êtes
mythos dans mon travail j'essaie de dire
ce que je pense mais en même temps comme
je suis romancier j'utilise la fiction
ouais donc je fais une réponse quand je
suis un mensonge qui dit la vérité
donc je mange avec beaucoup de sincérité
voilà vous me dîtes si ça suffit pas
vous arbitrez judith est ce que vous
êtes mégalo maîtresses judith net résume
ce que vous êtes des biens l'eau oui
complètement
ben oui seulement ça se voit pas soi
même temps je bosse j'essaie d'être le
plus humble c'est ce que montre avant la
glace ouais mais c'est comme l'ump en ce
moment et c'est d'être en maison du
marin le matin en me réveillant je me
regarde dans la glace je baisse les yeux
je regardais voilà je vous le fais là
non tirées non je suis pas mégalo
est ce que vous êtes parano pourquoi
vous me posez cette question touche est
ce que vous êtes schizo oui parce que
j'ai envie de c'est pas que je me
disperse mais je pense qu en fait
j'aimerais bien avoir des homonymes et
et avoir le don d'ubiquité
voila voila mon rêve c'est ça est ce que
vous êtes maso j'y travaille
allez à canal+ est un début
je
simplement je suis très douillet alors
je sais pas il aurait le courage
vraiment mais c'est agréable d'être maso
je crois enfin les vrais masochiste sont
des gens très paresseux qui sont
attachés on s'occupe 2,6
c'est pas mal de dos à dos oui oui mais
faire mal
oui c'est dans sa mairie oui c'est
agréable mais c'est fatigant c'est
l'avantagé pour ça je dis maso c'est
mieux parce qu'on n'a rien à faire
le sadi qui à la fin de la soirée oui
c'est bon quoi voilà exactement il faut
bosser à voici est ce que vous êtes
chaude au seau d'eau alors oui je suis
au dos je suis actif passif et cette
réponse va rester dans les annales et
que vous êtes vibro je ne vois pas de
raison de ne pas avoir recours aux
progrès de la science
[Applaudissements]
c'est tout ce qu'ils auraient à dire là
dessus est ce que vous êtes homo mais on
a dans un journal en 20 ans qualifié de
hétéro [__] et on va se qualifier de
quoi dans vingt ans ça la vraie vie de
[__] non mais je me suis habillé en
femme pour une soirée le bal des
débutantes
ouais et j'étais superbe avec une robe
emprunté et je ressemblais à valérie
lemercier dans palace ça fera plaisir
si tu nous regardes est ce que vous êtes
trio non je suis 17 au 22 euros mais je
vois pas l'intérêt de
de se limiter à trois personnes est ce
que vous êtes zoo je suis en fait pédo
zone et cros scato scatophile c'est à
dire que j'aime bien manger de la merde
de jeunes chiens bord si l'amour me
juger qui êtes vous il faudrait que
chacun ses petites habitudes
oui en même temps c'est tellement
service public on veut pas lui jeter la
pierre original
est ce que vous êtes mito non est ce que
vous êtes mégalo non plus c'est à dire
il faut il faut quand même confiance en
soi pour faire ça si on ne peut pas
monter sur scène et se livraient mettre
100 % de ce qu'on est ainsi qu'on n'a
pas une confiance en ce qu'on peut
donner n'ont plus de munitions et te
dirai moi j'ai été primé à 13 ans elle
elle l'a été
ouais ouais on connaît pas suspecte ah
non moi je suis entre au conservatoire
13 ans je n'ai pas encore pris mais je
vous aide pas à nos à huy assez
facilement ouais là par exemple non vous
pensez pas que la terre entière vous
annonce non pas par rapport à un
complexe qu'un complexe et persécutions
par rapport à une obsession du détail
est ce que vous êtes schizo non pas du
tout parce qu'on vit à douala hélène
grimaud de la musique la laine grimaud
des loups n'ont absolument pas du tout
est ce que vous êtes un port du mot mais
non je n'ai pas de carton rouge je n'ai
plus rien est ce que vous êtes kato est
ce que vous êtes maniaco oui enfin ça
dépend si vous voulez la maniaco
dépressive non ouais et maniaque oui lui
qu est ce que vous êtes narciso non plus
pour y est pourtant est-ce que vous êtes
fétiche aux non plus bien vous êtes et
c'est normal mais alors oui normal non
moi j'ai toujours essayé de
comment dire libre et de l' esclavage
par rapport à certaines certains objets
d'être attaché des choses matérielles
donc en fait le fétichisme ce n'est pas
pour moi tout est sale ou non bazot non
il ya une certaine jouissance dans la
souffrance
mais c'est une façon de s'élever ouais
ouais vous n'êtes pas sado maso vous
êtes trop co je sais quoi rococo vous
êtes trio non lundi quatre mains quand
même maintenant je suis trio dans
l'esprit de la visite
oui j'aime bien n'hésite plus rien
gardons c'était ce qui évite le fantasme
et des ministères c'est un oui
restons-en là est ce que vous êtes zowie
ça suffit aussi j'ai fait plein
d'animaux c'est bon nous faisons pas au
nom ouais parce que c'est quand même
réducteur
est ce que vous dites adamo c'est par
année c'est ce qui est pire
j'étais d'abord te rappelles dur j'étais
démo vous et exhibe au 7e tour non plus
est ce que vous êtes
magnéto ah oui ah ouais j'aime
l'enregistrement
ouais magnéto serdioukov
[Musique]
a sion sauvage est édité chez rona pour
maladie
[Musique]
marie ange alors sénateur loppsi est ce
que vous êtes
mythos non pas du tout non alors
vraiment pas du tout pas du tout me tôt
dans l'histoire du lion jamais vu les
images est ce que vous êtes diallo non
plus non plus lui non
vous êtes parano un soupçon un pas trop
pas trouve non la preuve faut deux ans
et demi de ta carte pour savoir pourquoi
moi c'est ce qu'ils au petit peu il ya
deux marie ange nardi guérilla urbaine
fils elle a été chez le toiletteur à le
passer vous êtes très bien coiffé ses
j'adore les créoles en plus moi donc les
skyzos quand même oui un petit peu oui
après disons que c'est un personnage à
plusieurs facettes
il ya celles qu'on connaît la télévision
comme ça l'animatrice préférée des
français
les pilot deux facettes c'est quoi c'est
quelqu'un peut être un peu plus un peu
plus
un peu plus fou que ce que les gens
imaginent met volontiers sa journée
l'impression c'est râpé commence
au nom donc pas forcément que des bonnes
choses un pas que de la bonne à bon chat
bon c'est pas que sexuelles non pas
sexuel je comprends rien est ce que vous
êtes cyclo un petit peu mais je ne fais
pas vivre sous harris et bien ce soir
vous êtes plutôt en haut ça va ouais ça
c'est plutôt bien
est ce vous êtes maso non pas vraiment
vous n'avez pas qu'on vous fasse mal non
non non je peux m'énerver assez fort
parce que je suis agressive méchamment
l'amour par exemple si un mec vous fait
mal à ça c'est pas l'agresser non mais
je n'avais pas compté ses interviews
psycho mais uniquement sur le plan d'eau
il voudrait passer le bac les taux il
est donc mal non mal non un vrai mal tu
vas laisser le temps que les taux
vazimba toi je vais pas que c'est
dommage je ne vais pas non j'ai ça
d'objets mais bien faire mal non ah bon
sado maso là j'en ai eu effectivement et
ce que vous êtes une info
qu'est ce que vous entendez exactement
par l'info une femme qui ne pas se
passer du sexe de l'homme qui a besoin
jour et nuit tous les chats
vous voulez dire par rapport à nomura
tous les hommes sous les termes on
l'entend habituellement non pléthore
d'hommes non non c'est quoi le fait de
l'info à la personne de combien c'est
pas tous les torts c'est très relatif à
chaque individu
c'est mon chiffre je peux pas le désir
chez ces bons chiffres de porter bonheur
vous êtes exhibo nom a pas du tout non
dit lesbo non non abah abah finalement
trio non plus non plus gérante aux
ménages non mais je n'ai pas encore
essayé nom puis tout ça oui ces mariages
et c'est un appel que vous faites si
j'ai branché par les quinquagénaires les
cages aux jeunes et obispo gelais était
plutôt début mai qu'elle en est ressorti
oui c'est bien c'est bien fait c'est dur
il ya pas de payer des patchs maintenant
je crois vous êtes rocco chamallows un
nom rocco à la cour avoir tiré
leur essai récent et bientôt 24 heures
encore
ça
bientôt on va faire une interview psy
d'accord un terme aux petits
est ce que vous êtes
mythos est ce que vous êtes
mégalo non plus est ce que vous êtes
paranos un peu non
ouais schizo non cyclo cyclomoteur timmy
oui je continue je vais pas mes fils
mais je n'en fais une excuse moi un état
[__] je suis là je viens claustro way
maniaco non maso non plus bob a un peu
quand même
j'étais naïve pendant quatre ans pour
venir la folle être un peu quand même
c'est vrai parce que vous êtes gérant de
tout ça c'est pour nous désirons tôt
quel âge ils alpes il est plus jeune que
nous ah oui bon donc à les jeunots ouais
donc aller les gigolos peut-être même
vous êtes gigolo il va plus jeune que
vous tout va bien je vous êtes vibro
j'ai essayé mais sans succès ah ouais
bonne foi de portable je vais être aux
cô tés de piccolo ou locaux en quoi
c'est trop et quand c'est trop
et
comment savez-vous jean marie bigard
bien de temps en temps mais pas toujours
mais des fois c'est pas mal quand même
assez souvent mais c'est pas toujours de
quoi aimeriez vous nous parler ce soir
est bien de mon prochain spectacle qui
s'appelle mon psy va mieux au comédia
arvida au comédia à partir du 15
répondre ead
si je vous demande de me raconter un
souvenir d'enfance n'importe lequel ce
serait quoi
non mon meilleur souvenir d'enfance
c'est la première fois que qu'une fille
m'a attrapé les roubignoles j'ai trouvé
ça extraordinaire parce que tu peux pas
le raconter ça c'est un cri pas un je me
suis dit si c'est ça la vie et ben je
suis d'accord pour continuer c'est quoi
l'expérience la plus traumatisante de ta
vie ta va serrer la main comme voilà
plus de dix ans de ma vie c'était de
perdre mes parents mais encore une fois
je les analyse et d'une manière puisque
c'est une interview au psy je pense que
c'est les étages de la fusée qui se
détache pour que la fusée
aïe plus haut et après coup donc trente
ans plus tard je me dis mais si j'avais
pas perdu mais mes parents jamais je
serai montanari jamais j'aurai connu
laurent baffie thierry ardisson toi non
mais c'est tout à fait raisonnable
raison tu en voilà un truc très sympa
c'est que tout arrive pour le mieux et y
compris le plus gros des emmerdements
tu as le choix ou de l'accepter ou de
renâcler et tu peux renâclé toute ta vie
est quelque chose de mauvais qui t'es
arrivé ou alors tu peux dire voilà une
est proche de la franchise je suis digne
de franchir l'obstacle donc je le
franchie dès l'enfance a eu besoin
d'être et mr bah je suis arrivé en
costume
ouais tous mes frères et soeurs ils sont
arrivés tout tordu il a fallu tirer
dessus et où moi je suis avait pas il a
fallu tirer sur le cordon pourquoi que
je me classe dans le mur face suis
arrivé j'ai fait et hop
et oui parce que j'ai le quatrième âge
était pas tellement désiré donc tu
arrivé en disant attendait me jetez pas
tout de suite
drôle c'est pour ça que je suis c'est
pour ça que je suis comique c'est pour
ça aussi que très souvent les artistes
les grands artistes les grands créateurs
les grades créateurs ne sont presque
jamais les premiers de la famille ce que
le premier tube uzi toujours un petit
peu tu as envie qu'il soit comme toi tu
as envie qu'ils fassent pas les
conneries que tu as fait tu prends donc
le dernier comme les les trois autres
d'avant ils ont déjà bien déblayé le
terrain
le quatrième année que ces expériences
plus libre il ce besoin de choquer tulle
explique comment mais va te faire
[__]
non je n'ai pas besoin je ne je ne me
considère pas comme quelqu'un de
choquant ah ouais non non si si à moins
que l'on n'ait jamais torcher le cul
d'un vieux à moins qu'on ait jamais fait
détruire non qu'est-ce que vous avez
encore du mal à contrôler dans la vie
mais colère ouais vous êtes quoi les
relais l'injustice ouais ouais et la
colère ça j'ai du mal à régler le
curseur vite j'ai eu envie de mourir
jean-marie j'ai tout le temps un petit
peu envie c'est une des plaies graves
oui non mais l'idée est ce que la vérité
comme jeudi lorsqu'elle j'ai vraiment
pas peur d'eux
de la mort j'ai peur comme tout le monde
de souffrir que ça dure longtemps
d'avoir une déchéance voie longue et
pénible et tout mais sinon le mort si
elle vient aujourd'hui elle est la
bienvenue
le plus tard sera le mieux parce que je
suis pas suicidaire mais ouais mais ça
me fait pas peur elle vient quand il
veut je l'attend cet [__] là
qu'avez-vous enfin compris sur vous j'ai
compris que je n'étais que une toute
petite partie de l'univers qu'il fallait
pas trop s'affoler et que la vie était
vraiment un jeu et que le mieux c'était
de jouer encore
ouais vous acceptez bien ne pas avoir
d'enfant je l'acceptent
en tout cas j'ai les enfants des autres
et puis d'avoir le sien on n'est jamais
sûr que c'est le sien ouais c'est je
vais dire un truc et on fera un contrôle
sur l'ensemble de la planète à saveur
c'est vrai que c'est pas ces mamans sur
papa peut-être
et puis on peut toujours à adopter ils
en font des autres et des filiales
absolument par exemple ça déjà été tenté
par une aventure avec un homme
non franchement non c'est un truc de me
ccc physique je suis pas je suis pas
contre 1 ont des fois on s'embrasse
quand on fait les cons sans voix sur la
bouche avec la langue on le fait un coup
tous les deux c'est cet attrait pour le
sexe la taille du sexe sur vos affiches
de spectacles etc
ce trail pas une angoisse par rapport à
la taille réelle à votre sexe non non
non non parce que c'était vraiment pour
hugo léger mis des balles de tennis j'ai
un sexe qui est normal à refaire ouais
j'en suis assez content pourquoi vous
avez besoin de toucher les cours y tout
le temps jean-marie mais pourquoi tu dis
ça
donc maintenant on va vérifier si
emmanuelle gaume à un problème
d'instabilité interview psy on ne bouge
pas pendant le mandat bush en avant
leurs deux bouge pas pendant les
problèmes ne bouge pas pendant le dingle
[Musique]
connard moi c'est laurent mais je suis
ravi de connaître ton prénom est ce que
vous êtes mégalo
petit chou et un petit chou et c'est sa
vie un petit choi non qui se fait un
petit peu toshiya j'apprends ici c'est
bien oui c'est bien non il faut venir
tous les samedis ici on apprend match
man des trucs service public est-ce que
vous êtes mito menteuse
j'adore sales mensonges parano en ces
périodes de l'année un peu ce mercato
attendant c'est normal parce que vous
êtes schizo non j'ai un ouais un vrai
don d'ubiquité je préfère ubiquité à
schizophrénique geoffrey nice est plus
proche de la folie chez pas du tout
dingue tu arrives à suivre vous êtes
cyclo cyclothymique
ouais mais aujourd'hui c'est quoi c'est
la peau d'âne là à l'instant présent
superbe ce matin c'était totalement
dingue mais ça va vous êtes je pleure
rit moi mais ça c'est pas mal comme la
vie comme les filles très méfiant comme
nous aussi parce que mon espèce ou aline
bordel c'est l'épaule en cinq minutes on
y va j'aime le clasico si l'occident est
bien sûr moi je prends pas vivre sans
les connaître pour un petit truc là non
mais patrick juvet j'aime bien si
patrick juvet
c'est compliqué parce que je vais bien
est ce que vous êtes maso ah non mixtes
est ce que vous êtes exhibo tichri la
faf est bien petit chou c'est quoi c'est
beaucoup pour une excuse est lesbo non
pas 10 juillet non pas du tout j'ai
vraiment été bon et hétéros et héros s
est borné à un pas du tout genre du ca
je vous êtes ado j'adore les ados
j'adore les enfants
gérante au nom c'est moi mon truc
est ce que vous êtes trio un trio fou
non franchement non vous êtes quoi je
suis très classique vraiment non verbal
pour vous un adieu moureu way zune et
rocco les grosses grosses lances par un
truc tout alors
est ce que vous êtes adamo à nouveau dit
ouf
[Musique]
finalement alors donc vous êtes une
fille très très normal finance ou de
perversion noms ne disent rien mais
jules et julot oui mais voilà
dans tous les cas sur france 3 avec
drôle de gars prochaine émission le 6
juin
michel blanc et le 12 juin avec
dominique a maintenant vous avez vexé
baffie la baci revient
wisekey la montre est vu comme ça je
pourrai juger sur fifa pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez
vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu